Good. All right. We live, uh,
this is a perfect time for me to talk
to you about this because I just took a
yoga class and had a vegan
lunch. Awesome. How do you feel?
I feel like numb. [inaudible]
I feel centered. Yeah.
I feel like my shockers are in line.
I feel fine. What were you, were,
you were to have a Vegan lunch?
Did you,
did you travel over there with like costs?
Drop a note to like a car without
leather seats? No, no, no. It was, yeah,
it's not really a Vegan lunch. Like
the car had leather seats. Yes.
So they also on top of that, like
your Tofu, was it meat flavored? No,
I didn't have tofu would
just add vegetables. Okay.
Well vegetables that
taste like vegetables.
I did kill a mosquito as
soon as I got out of my car,
so I don't think that's Vegan either.
Well, sounds like you're a murderer.
Sounds like it to me. Corey. Uh,
if you don't know that Knowlton last week,
right where we're at,
pronounced y'alls name, you've got, um,
one of the reasons why I wanted
to have you on this podcast is a,
I'm a big fan of Jim Shockey.
Jim Shockey show the
uncharted show and um,
something's going up my nose and
I'd seen you, uh, on that show.
So when the controversy broke,
a CNN covered the story for
folks who don't know what
we're talking about, Corey,
um,
you bid money to be one of the people
that got a chance to kill a black rhino.
Um,
for people who are not aware of
how conservation and hunting work,
what they try to do,
especially with endangered species,
is they have to sometimes protect
endangered species from their own.
And it seems very counterintuitive,
um,
for people who are on the outside
looking in, you say, well,
this is an endangered animal.
Why are you killing one of these
endangered animals and trying to call this
conservation. But with rhinos in
particular or a lot of aggressive animals,
even giraffes, the older males,
the older bulls, the older,
um,
non breeding members of these groups.
Sometimes we'll attack the young males
and killed them and females and females
and Kat cab,
you'll kill everything.
And it is just a natural part of being a
wild animal when the numbers are strong
and healthy. It's like it happens
in bears every day of the week.
It's just a part of being a bear.
But when it happens with, uh,
something that's endangered,
like a black rhino,
they're forced into a very peculiar
situation where they have to most likely
either kill or put this
animal in captivity. My right.
A lot of different, uh, different
situations depending on the animal,
what's actually doing.
Right. But yes, I mean,
some of the things you're talking about,
could it apply?
And this is where it
gets counter intuitive.
So they have a bid and the
bid gets to you. You want it,
what does it, $350,000, correct?
Yes. It's a lot of fucking money.
Um, and you went over
there, you shot this rhino.
All that money went towards aiding the
rhino was there wasn't enough money.
It wasn't,
and it should have been a lot more money
because they need more money or perhaps
more money.
And,
and the value of that was greater than
that amount of money was that was the
amount of money that I was able
to call together and make happen.
The anti hunting community in the animal
rights community came out so strongly
against this situation for what I think,
either misunderstanding or they were
trying to keep the contribution down.
Um,
one of the other or both.
And there's people who were much wealthier
than I am and had a lot more money
who really wanted to spend the money,
but at the time,
I don't think that they, they had a better
idea of what was to come than I did.
I guess I was a little bit naive
about it. Um, but these people are,
a couple of them are very
well known people and I don't
think they wanted to put
their employees and their company
and you know, they're alive.
They're family to the same things
that I ended up going through. And um,
they were basically chased out
by the anti hunting communities,
rhetoric and their attacks.
What, what was surprising to
you about this whole experience?
Because it had to be a pretty
life changing experience.
Like you're a guy who's a,
you know,
relatively famous in the hunting world,
you being on that Jim Shockey show and
you decide that you want to be the guy.
So you,
you spend all this money out.
What was your goal when
you wanted to do this?
Did you want to bring awareness to this?
Was it something that you felt
strongly about from the very beginning?
I've always felt very strongly about
conservation and hunting. Okay.
Ever since I was young and,
um,
but the way this came about was a
friend of mine who runs a company called
conservation for us,
or a nonprofit five zero one c three.
And he came to me and said,
look,
the people I had that are
bidding on this are gone.
And he asked me if I would bid on it.
And the bid that I made was basically
within very close to the minimum bid.
There was really no one else
really. Yeah. The minimum bid was
$350,000. You got to keep them on.
They sell these over or
in Namibia,
they have auctions amongst themselves.
This was the first one that
took place in the United States.
That's why I brought so much publicity.
This wasn't the first rhino,
it was to be brought
into the United States.
So this is something that happened before,
just not on a public stage
in the United States.
So they are able to get a certain amount
of money already for them and they
wanted to get more over here.
That was the whole idea.
And so they brought it over here.
Um,
the permanent of the Namibian
ministry environment,
tourism him and basically they're in,
um,
one of the rhino experts in the
country came over and took place.
They were there at the auction
when it took place. So the,
the amount of money that gets raised,
it's this enormous amount of
$350,000 in your opinion is low.
It would've probably been much
more if there wasn't, yeah.
Not In the opinion of many, in
fact, low. And I believe, um,
it'll come about again,
but probably in a different way.
And it's going to be at least,
I would say three times higher.
So they're going to do it again.
I don't think they're going to do it
again in the fashion they did though.
Absolutely.
Going to do it again,
but they're not gonna do it in a fashion
they did this time. I don't think.
I can't. I look, I don't speak for
them, so I don't know. But yes,
they will continue to auction off these
surplus rhinos and it's not hard to get
people to,
to be willing to do this,
but in order to get people to spend
$350,000 to save the Rhino just to,
just to donate, to save it without
hunting, it's pretty difficult.
I actually think that's
more complicated too,
because in this situation that I was in,
the money had to be proved to go to
the right places to benefit the rhino.
The Path had to be proven to the u s
fish and wildlife for them to grant the
import permit.
So it was went through the process,
which was like the most vetted
process possible on every level.
It was the most vetted conservation
hunt probably in history.
And they do these haunts like this
here in the United States all the time.
They auction off dear it's special
deer tags, special elk tags,
special sheep tags. Okay. This,
this year I was an auction where
a mule deer tag went for $385,000.
So they do these all
the time to raise money.
So it's not like a, uh, a new idea.
But in this case it was the most vetted
way for the money to get to the source
that,
and I believe in conservation,
I believe in hunting as a means as a
tool to help perpetuate it and keep these
animals alive.
So I had a personal vested
interest in the process,
so it,
and there's other people like me who
feel the same way and they are happy to
donate to that. Like you're saying
just to get somebody to do it. Well,
where do I give it to? How do I know
the money's going in the right place?
It's like similar to like,
I dunno if you know about the,
the Red Cross controversy.
Did you see that?
That just came out a couple of
days ago about Haiti that uh,
they millions and millions and millions
of dollars went to Haiti to do,
to help people after, what was
it, the big earthquake they had?
Is that what it was? And they
built like five houses. Like they,
they don't even know where
most of fucking money, man.
It's just a complete fuck fast.
He'll get this half a billion
dollars spent, six homes built.
Jesus Christ.
Well,
I think that speaks to the point that I
was trying to make and that's obviously
a different scenario. We're talking,
who knows? Who knows what that is?
You're looking at, you look at your news
source. Their salon.com is the greatest.
Yeah, very good. Unbiased.
They love everyone equally.
So what did they have to say
about you? Anything mean? Well,
yes, most, most, most everybody
who had an agenda to it,
that was against what the whole process,
what I was doing.
And this goes from all the way from the
head of the US fish and wildlife too,
you know, trying to make, make
it look like sideways. And I,
I you art the world's foremost experts.
Okay.
Especially on those companies.
What does that IUC ends up, um,
group that puts together in the red
list of endangered species. Okay.
They are the foremost experts on this
subject and a guy named Michael Knight
heads up that African Rhino specialist
group and he's the foremost expert in the
world on rhinos. Okay. So you got,
you have the world's foremost
experts in this. You had to WWF,
a guy named Chris Weaver in Namibia
who heads that up yet WWF behind it,
you got IUC and behind it yet side, he's
behind it. You got us fish and wildlife,
which, you know, I come down on
two different sides with them.
Sometimes I agree with them,
sometimes I don't. Okay.
But in this case I
absolutely agree with them.
So you had like the foremost authorities
in the world all agreeing with this.
And then you have a large amount of people
who type in 75 characters on Twitter
and feel better about it. And
you know, they're, they're,
they're weighing in and
in today's Day and age,
you look at that and it's like a handful
of people who are emotional about
something outweigh public.
You know, I mean, the experts
of the world opinion, well,
it'd be,
becomes very controversial first of all,
because it went on at the same time as
they were broadcasting another species of
rhino that was going extinct.
There was three of them left,
one male to women, and uh, the,
the mail wasn't breeding with them
and they were like, this is it.
You're looking at the last three
of these rhinos. Sure. And it also,
part of the reason is it falls into
this category that people called trophy
hunting.
And it's very different than going to
the supermarket and buying meat from an
animal that was killed for meat.
The idea of trophy hunting bothers a
lot of people because they think what
you're doing as you're going over there
and you shooting something to prop up
your ego, you shooting something because
you know you want to be the master,
you want to go over there and blast this
thing and take a picture of grip and
grin and smile.
I think that's like a,
I'm sure throughout
history that's existed,
but I don't think that that's a accurate
representation of people who you can
call trophy hunting,
whatever you want. I mean,
you can put it on if you're out there
looking for the biggest cow elk because
you want the meat.
All right?
And you're being selective about
which one you're picking. Okay.
So if for what the truth about,
let's quote unquote trophy hunting is
you're going out there looking for the
most mature male of the species
that you can find. Okay.
And you're going through a selective
process and I think there is amongst
hunters, there's definitely
a movement going. You know,
Jim and I used to talk about it
all the time. We would go out,
we're looking for the oldest male
of the species we can find. Okay?
Because that's the best one to take out.
He's already breeded
he's going to go down,
he's going to fall over dead on the
mountain if it's a ram and birds are going
to pick his eyes out while he's alive,
okay?
He's going to go through a horrible death
and we're going to spare that animal
that.
And so there's a lot that goes into
that and I understand people say,
okay, that's what it is, Joe.
Like for instance, you know,
I just met you today and my idea of
who you are isn't who Joe Rogan is.
The only person that knows who Joe Rogan
is as Joe, I think some of the cable. No,
Jamie knows. Okay, well,
whatever. All right. In reality,
you the only person that,
okay, your thoughts. Okay? My
point is I can't put why you,
the decisions you've got brought
you to where you are right now.
I don't know what that is.
Okay. And in this case,
I had hundreds of thousands
of people at the soccer.
of people trying to say,
you did this for this reason. Right.
They don't know what reason I did it for.
Right. They never talked to me. They
never met me. Okay. And so yeah. Okay.
You want to go ahead and lump everybody
in there cause it's easy for you to
disenfranchise them. Well you're,
you're defending yourself here.
And I would be defensive
too if I experienced the
kind of barrage of hate that
I've seen leveled your way.
But that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to have you on is give you a chance
over, you know, a couple
hours to speak your mind.
And so what people have a problem with
I think is people that want to kill
things and don't eat them.
There's some people that have a problem
with eating meat is some people that
have a problem with eating
fish. Some people, you know,
some people go deep with it,
right?
I think there's varying degrees of
outrage when it comes to people killing
animals. But at the top of that list
is what they call trophy hunting.
And that's an,
and that's someone who kills it,
that doesn't have any
intention of eating it.
Have you killed a mature a
mule deer because it has a,
an awesome rack and you're still
gonna eat that animal shit.
You're going to donate it. You're gonna do
something with it. Yeah, it's delicious.
And it's, it's, there's a reason
why people hunt them cause they,
they taste fantastic. It's high
quality proteins. Great for you.
You're not eating a rhino, right?
Did you eat it? Absolutely.
The first thing you just did it right
there on the spot. Did you? Absolutely.
What does it taste like? It
was better than elephant.
Really? You eat an elephant?
Sure. Whoa. What does that taste
like? Not as good as rhino.
So what part of the rhino do you eat raw?
Well,
we delivered the entire thing
to a whole village. You know,
our group wasn't hungry enough to
eat the entire rhino right there.
I would imagine. How many thousands
of pounds was this thing, by the way?
I guess it was between 20 503,000
would be my guess. Large animal.
And this, uh, did they have
any refrigeration in this
village or is this just a,
you know, to the extent, no,
there was so many people that that
wasn't going to be a large issue.
Yeah. I've seen that before with
an elephant hunt on television.
It was a documentary on the
controversy in um, these, uh,
hunting camps in South Africa and they
shot this elephant and donate it to these
villagers.
These people came with baskets and stuff,
these baskets with elephant meeting and
they cut that entire carcass down to
bite size portions or meal size portions
and just a matter of a few hours.
It was insane.
It was crazy to watch.
So when people think of
this being just a waste,
just killing the Santa
wrong, they're wrong. 100%.
That wasn't really discussed at all in
the news that was never covered and never
see one article that covered the fact
that they said it to people. We did.
There's a video of it on CNN. Did
they shut article? Absolutely.
Eating of it to the capitol. I got
pictures of it on my phone. There you go.
I'll show you. I believe you 100%
we'll look question. We'll look.
I want to show you.
Okay.
You're sitting across from me right
now and I'm looking at the CNN article.
I don't see any pictures of it. I was
going in the video to the meat delivery.
Just is there a link in there? It
should be. I've got it on my phone,
but for instance,
here's me standing in front of the village
of Selfie with the entire rib cages
of that animal.
Whoa.
Let me see. After the black rhino hunt,
a village celebrates meet delivery.
Oh, okay. This is, it is a separate
video other than one that I had watched,
which was the title of that was Texas
Hunter bags is rhino and controversial
hunt and then maybe, uh, yeah,
so not so controversial to the people
that you've delivered the meat to.
Absolutely. Not those people,
like if you look at them,
they're very excited to get
this protein, um, an elephant.
Yeah.
The idea of meet wastage in Africa
isn't that look in the United States,
it's hard for us to comprehend it because
we've got a system of such excess that
the poorest, we'll keep it by the
poorest among us are the most overweight.
You go to Africa, a poor person is
skin and bones. Right. Okay. You know,
people will say the money,
money is the root of all evil.
Poverty's a root of all evil. You go over
there and see it firsthand is horrible.
And so they're not wasting announced
to that meat. Now this, uh,
this animal had been targeted
because it killed one,
a young bull already and it was an older
angry male with not a whole lot of time
left. Right? Is that the
idea? That's correct. And it,
I believe it had killed more
than that through its life.
It had been transported
already to this area,
like when it was around 19 years old.
And how old are they live?
I'll look.
I saw list that had been there and
they had them alive in the field,
visited over 37 years old.
Wow.
So you know they leave at least that long.
You're not that old. How old
are you? I'm 36 years old.
How long have you been doing
this big game? Wild hunting.
Then I got into it when I was a strike.
Started guiding Hans
when I was 16 years old.
You started guiding hunts
when you're 16 my first,
my first I graduated high school.
I was guiding hunts through high school.
What kind of hunted Whitetail, like
ducks and the ducks and geese and stuff,
and then I slowly got into hunting. It's
what? It just became a passion to me.
We grew up real,
real poor.
I just laugh all the time when I
see people talk about how, you know,
like I'm some rich over,
you know,
super talk about my family in
the oil business and whatnot.
I was already before my,
my brother and my father,
their partner had any success
in the whole business. Man.
I was in my twenties I was, you know, I'd
already charted my path and was going.
I said I wasn't aware of your back when
I was going to ask you that too. Yeah.
Where the fuck did you come up with
$350,000 a lot. Well, you know, luckily,
I mean I've been successful in life and
especially in the Huntington and so I
was very successful in guiding hunts
and in setting up punts. That's,
that's how Jim and I got together.
I was booking hunts all around the world.
But anyway,
so I started when I was like,
I'm 16 taking people duck and goose
hunting in Texas is obviously a different
place. I don't know how much time you
spent in Texas, but hunting Texas. Yeah.
Texas hunting and fishing
as it is a part of my,
it's just for the most part
it's very accepted. Okay.
And even if you don't do it,
you have a family member that does,
you've got a buddy that worked
does, and so people are, I mean,
I'm telling people in Texas
aren't that judgmental really.
I mean about this at least. And so, um,
anyway,
I w w you know,
we're all growing up together as a family
and it's a part of our thing, you know,
and my granddad were, I mean, I grew up
in poverty. When I was real young and, uh,
what we had to do was go
hunting and fishing, you know,
and we, we, we got, I mean,
I didn't ever got,
I don't think I shot my first deer
till I was 15 or 16 years old. And, um,
so I did this bird hunting and then I
graduated high school and I went and got a
job, uh, working for a guy in
Colorado, gotten mountain lion hunts.
And then I, you know, got another,
started another business up with floor
tile and made money and I was saving my
money up to go hunting. And I met
another guy, a guy named Erin Nielsen.
And Him and I started up a company
together and we started taking people on
hunts. We'd say, we'd go on
these different hunts in ourself.
We'd go there and find the area,
check it out and go on these adventures
and then come back and get people
together and go on more of them.
And it's kind of snowballing so well,
when I met Jim and 2001 or two back then,
um, you know, I was just getting into it.
And I already knew quite a bit,
not already hunted Africa.
I'd already gone through a
lot of places in the world.
And I'm just got into it and said,
Hey Jim, do you want to go to Africa?
And we went and that was his first
African trip. And uh, we went over there,
had a great trip,
filmed it for the video at the time.
He goes on and becomes more
successful and his TV stuff.
I keep doing what what I did.
And then a few, few years later,
we came up with this idea to start this
TV show about our lives as professionals
in the hunting industry. And we
called it the professionals. And, um,
cause personally Jim and
I would talk about it,
and I'm not gonna speak down about
these people that are at the time on the
outdoor television world,
you know,
which is a different thing than most TV.
And a lot of ways,
I think you've talked about it on your
podcast before. Um, we were like, well,
a lot of these people are calling,
they're saying they're professionals,
but they're getting like a free boat.
You know,
we're actually making our
livings doing this, you know,
taking people hunting and
outfitting and guiding and whatnot.
And we just want to also the quality
of the show. Yeah, true. Yeah.
Shows they're excellent.
They're really well done.
Especially uncharted could easily be
on the discovery channel or the history
channel. [inaudible] is a great show.
Yeah. And so that was kind of our goal.
We wanted to chronicle this and make
the production level as high as we could
and, and show people that, you know,
there is a human side of this and
then that's what was our goal.
So do you get frustrated when you watch?
Like there's some reality,
we're not reality shows.
There's some hunting shows that
are on television that you know,
are essentially like cable access shows.
I mean,
it just really poorly made bad editing,
bad personalities.
I mean that's those guys dream.
I'm not going to say I get frustrated
at it, you know, it's just like,
it's just like everybody
who plays baseball not going
to be making manall. Right.
I mean like when people flip through the
channels and they pause him auto shows
and they, that that's their
exposure to hunting. Yeah. I mean,
uh, I don't know that
every single one of them,
even ours would be a true representation
of all of hunting. You know what I mean?
So it's hard, you know. Um, I feel
like we strive for that. I really,
I mean personally, it,
look, I watched a lot.
I don't watch hunting shows because
I lived it, you know what I mean?
I really lived it to the fullest.
I've been everywhere I could have
ever dreamed of and seeing everything.
So it's hard for me to watch
it. You know, it'd be like you,
you're going outside of all the
fights you've watched him, you know,
are you going to get really
excited about watching two bumps?
Duke it out in front of the studio?
Unfortunately. Yes. It's so good.
It's so good at what you do.
I like watching little kids
beat each other up. Okay.
Alright. Sorry. As long
as nobody gonna Miss. Um,
but I see your point. I
totally see your point. Um,
so you started out hunting essentially
for food? Well, yeah. Well, no.
For it was part, we ate it hard to live
our life, you know? I mean, I grew up,
we went hunting. We, we, we shot does
we shock? Well, we ate them. Okay.
We went fishing. We were catching
release and boiling Greece. Right. Okay.
We were catching Krabi and eating them.
That was part of life.
How do you go from that to
shooting an elephant will,
if you really like hunting and you go
over there and you learn more about it,
you know, and you have
a passion for it. You,
if that's what you want to do,
you just go. Right. But what,
what leads you to want
to shoot an elephant?
Like what personally?
Yes.
I just loved hunting.
I love the idea of being out there.
I love the idea of
being with local people.
I love the idea of seeing
the way it worked in other
parts of the world. I mean,
I had like,
I had a burning,
crazy desire to go experience nature.
Right.
Okay. And, and,
and be a part of the cycle of life in
an intimate way everywhere I could go.
Like people don't realize it, I
don't think. And it's hard, you know,
like I'm really,
and I'll get into it later with you.
I'm really interested to hear
your path that brought you to it.
I'm sure you've talked on it and we don't
have to talk on it cause you probably
are right now. It
doesn't bother, you know,
if you've talked about your listeners
get bored of it or whatever,
but I'd really like to know it. Okay.
Because you, you, you probably understand,
I don't want to like speak for you,
but when you're that close to an animal,
when you're within bow range of an animal,
it's a different experience than you
have going to seven 11 or whatever.
You're going to have a normal life.
And so in a way that would be
the way I would translate it.
I just wanted to go everywhere I possibly
could and I read everything I possibly
could and I learned everything I
possibly could, especially about,
I had a real passion for Asia.
I've hunted all over Asia everywhere that
I could go in Asia. I went, you know,
I could, I could go down the
list, do that, astonish you.
And so I went over there and an
Asian hunting has by and large,
brutally hard was that, I
mean, I mean we went to Nepal.
Europe is almost 17,000 feet. You
know, you walk in, you walk out,
you know, your whole camp is being
carried in or carrying out a lot of times.
And if your backpack, honey, you're
carrying everything you live in, you know,
I mean,
I'm 36 years old going on like 86 years
old because of all the diseases and
stuff my body's been through, you
know, for doing IA and all that shit.
I'll never had Giardia,
but I had a,
I had one they couldn't figure
out the Mayo Clinic one time like,
and it was killing me. And then
I had malaria had that. Um,
I've had numerous other infectious
diseases that were destroying me at 20,
let me think,
was 22 years old.
I got malaria and my fever got so bad
that my gums were immediately like a 40
year old person. So your gums,
like a fever, damage your guns,
like guns, I guess I'm not a
doctor and just what they told me.
But it's what happens to
your gums and oil man.
It's something that has to do with high
fever for a long time. I don't know.
So it just like makes your gums recede,
dude. Malaria is a bad deal. Yeah.
I've had a friend who had malaria. Yeah.
And so I didn't catch it until later.
Part of the problem is like the medicines
they give you make you feel bad, right?
So you don't really notice
it coming on at first.
It's almost better in some circumstances
just not to take the prophylactics.
And I'm gonna say anybody should do that.
But personally I do that a lot.
And once I just know I'm an
Esol and malaria area and
then you'll know that it's
coming on sooner because by the
time it hit me, I was really sick.
So you're talking about the anti malaria
medication you take before you get it?
Yes.
Yeah.
I had a friend who took that and he
was drinking and apparently you're not
supposed to take it and drink.
And he went crazy.
Like he got violent and apparently I'll
personally Laurium the one you take once
a day. It was exactly
what it was. Yeah. Yeah.
It'll make you hallucinate and freak out.
But people hear you say that you
have a passion for it, you know,
and that you love being in wildlife
and I understand that. But they,
the big question would be, why not
just go there and see those animals?
Like why would you want to go and kill
an elephant? Like what is, what is it?
What is it about? I, you
know, it's the same thing.
It's hard for hard for me to
put it in words, but I mean,
I believe that human beings
are part of the cycle of life.
I believe your eyes or in
the front of your head.
I believe you have canine teeth,
not for eating.
Eating salad sounds good for you though.
It's great. Eat it. Have it out. Okay.
And so I believe that's why you have them.
I believe that we are predators.
I believe it's a part of us.
Right?
And so for me to explain something that
is a part of me, it's hard like that.
It's hard for me to say. And, and, and
I think people get caught up in what?
You just enjoy the killing it. It's
like you don't, you don't hunt to kill.
It's you killed who have
hunted in a lot of ways.
And I've been on 12 on the hunt
to kill you kill to have hunted.
What do you mean by that?
If you're a hunter,
you're going out hunting, you're not going
out killing. If I liked killing things,
I'd work at the Chili Chicken plant and
I get 11,000 chickens every day if I
really got a thrill out of killing
stuff. Okay. And I've gone on,
I've gone on 12 like hunts that I
went on unsuccessful. She punts.
And those were some of the
best times that I've ever had.
And it wasn't anything about killing the
animal or not killing an animal. Yeah,
that's a goal.
But that was kind of part of the
reason that brought me to those places.
You're not going to go to these
places, man, for no reason. Okay?
You're not thinking, when people
think about, you know, Africa,
they're thinking about the Masai Mara
and a nice east African or or Kruger park
type photo safari.
You're not going into darkest Africa
on the border of the Congo or in,
in the Congo or you know,
these are nasty places in the
world to go take pictures.
Most people aren't going to do it.
Not Nice. Even the photo people,
you're going to get to
like the raw still the raw,
they're going to go and do that stuff.
It's brutal on you. It's not comfortable.
You go out and hang out with, you know,
with pygmies who are very tough people,
for instance, who had been to Cameroon
and they're waking up every morning.
A lot of them, you know,
their lives are hard. Okay?
It's not a nice existence and you
go out there and exist with them.
It's a different thing.
So you,
you feel compelled to go to these places.
I would be compelled to
hunt. Absolutely. But an
see people have like if they've
found out you're killing, you know,
an antelope or something like that seems
normal. You know, you shooting that,
you eat it.
But shooting an elephant to people,
they have a hard time with it because
they're intelligent and they're social
creatures and they know each
other for they having same mess.
All these animals are
intelligent. Are they really
whitetail deer? They're hunted.
They're really intelligent wolf. Extremely
intelligence are very intelligent.
Yeah. Okay. Look in, in, in,
in a, in a white, in a night,
in eight way to stay alive.
They're very,
they're much more intelligent about their
environment than you and I ever would
because that's their home
and they live in it. So
it's a, it's a different
thing. And elephants, are
they intelligent? Absolutely.
Okay. Did they have ethics and emotions?
No, I mean, outside of, you know,
Raul is form. I think it, I've been around
animals that I thought were angry. Well,
they definitely have emotions, right?
They, they get upset at dead loved ones,
but ethics,
it's a human construct and there you go.
And that's what happens is when people
are trying to apply human constructs to
animals, what right does the antelope
have not to be killed by the Jaguar
are, or I'm sorry, the Leopard
[inaudible] what? Right.
Does it have not to be killed
by the Leopard? I mean it's,
it's a part of its life that's,
that makes sense to people.
What doesn't make sense as the desire?
I think for some people there's a desire
to go over there and shoot beautiful
animals. The whitetail deer is beautiful.
It's killed everyday. I agree. Okay.
But it seems normal to people because
it's killed every day because we kill it
and we eat an elephant. Seems like
something that you see at the circus.
It seems like something that's in between.
There you go. There's a whole thing.
There's 250,000 elephants
in sub Sahara and Africa.
How in danger did that sound to
you? Yeah, that's, I, that's true.
I wanted to get to that. But the
car you asked, normal people,
the average person with the
average, um, you know, uh,
exposure to elephants and they think
they're in danger. Okay. Unfortunately,
that's not true in south subs. I have
an act for Africa in places like Cjr.
It's true.
They're in trouble.
And in these places sometimes
they actually have to kill
these elephants because
they start encroaching and human territory
and was just regulation and control.
I know a guy who killed 1200
elephants. Jesus Christ. Okay,
1200 why did he do that?
Population control.
So he lives down there. Yeah. Well I
don't even know if he's still alive now.
But anyway, yeah, that was his thing.
He worked for the government killed him.
And when you do this,
you have to spend a considerable amount
of money to kill an elephant, right?
Not necessarily, no. Do you consider
a considerable amount of money?
How much does it cost? I mean, you
can go over there sometimes. I mean,
I know people who've shot him for a
couple thousand dollars you could shoot an
elephant for a population you're not,
you're not bringing the Tufts, Columbia,
just shooting it and then
the village eating it.
And what do they do with the tusks?
And that would be like on a cow,
probably just a female. And population
troll. I mean, the, the least
that I've ever heard of anybody
shooting a bull elephant for, you know,
in recent times, probably like
$8,000, 6,000, 8,000 bucks.
And then the government just keeps the
tongue and the government keeps a Tusk
and does what with them? I don't
know. It depends on what, you know,
what did they put them in storage.
I don't know exactly what
they do with them then.
That's a weird thing
because of the ivory trade,
like the poaching and the ivory trade.
I mean,
that's what we see all the time when
we connect elephants with death.
We see these animals,
they're sawed off tasks and you know,
and then the rest was left behind.
That's poachers, criminals,
horrible criminals. So if you go
over and you shoot an elephant,
it should a bull elephant. You can't
bring the tusks back. Yes, you can.
You can't in certain,
like if you shoot one in South Africa and
Namibia right now, you can import them.
You can absolutely. I thought there was
a ban on importing Henry only and uh,
they, they shut down Zimbabwe
until they changed their structure.
It's not because there's not enough
elephants there. They have, you know,
thousands and thousands
of elephants in Tanzania.
They shut down the port for for
different reasons, you know,
with regards to the poaching,
whatnot.
And so the only thing that kills elephants
is rarely lions will kill them. Right.
Um, I taught other than people, other
elephants, other elephants. Yeah.
And so it's one of those apex animals
that if people don't step in and do
something about the population,
destroy the habitat and they can get
out of Botswana. Botswana's Trad. Yeah.
Eastern Botswana. It's bad that
they destroyed. It's like a tornado.
A lot of places.
I went to a place to,
the place that I hunted elephant wasn't
Botswana and it really looked like a
hurricane had come through.
It just looked like the whole
landscape was demolished.
And it was just because of
Alpha. Absolutely. You're
dealing with some enormous,
I mean, how much is it big
elephant way, you know,
I mean,
well over 10,000 pounds.
He was 14 I mean the biggest
one I've probably seen,
I would have guessed at 14 foot tall.
It's a huge animal.
It's a different experience. Hunting an
elephant. Yeah. I would imagine. You know,
it's a totally different thing and you,
the thing that you have to understand
that there's different reasons to have
different things. Okay. You know,
it's not like a hunting
is some giant just broad
stroke and in, in the
case of elephants, you,
if you want people to,
to have a positive benefit.
Local people who really determined
like the survival of any animals,
local people. Okay. You have to put
a positive benefit on it for them.
If it's just living next door to
an elephant, you don't want that.
If it's living next door to align,
you don't want that. Okay. And,
and so you're trying to understand that
you have to give them a reason to keep
it there or it's not going to be there.
Did you ever see Louis
Thoreau's documentary on
the hunting camps in Africa?
It's very interesting. It's very good.
If you don't know who Louis throw his,
he's a documentary in from the UK and uh,
he,
he really gets very,
very thorough on subjects and he spent
a lot of time in this South African
hunting camp but it got down
to the end of it and you know,
he was pastoring this guy who ran this
camp to the point where the guy said you
had done get it Avi guy, he's fucked.
He goes, it's fucked. He goes,
they destroy.
The only way she's going to keep
these fucking animals is if there were
something that's been a front page.
I think it was a,
the way you're talking about he was yeah,
but anyway,
it's 100% but that's what he said,
Dude said it has to be worth something.
I look at it like the people in a lot of
people in Western world are looking at
it through an a theorial missed and not
getting it. Like if it is, if it pays,
it will stay period. Right. If
it pays, it's going to stay.
Do you think that part of the problem
with people and their perceptions of
hunting is just based on this really weird
insulated world that we live in where
you could just go to the store and buy
meat and most people hold on all the vast
majority of hundred
percent let me be clear.
100% that's the problem.
That is the problem.
They knew it and in addition to that,
they think that team own and Pumba who
are Disney characters created by a couple
of guys and drawing up and
given personalities. My
daughters love them. Okay,
and so did mine. Okay, but
they're not real. Exactly. Okay.
The real team own and Puma are out there
fighting for their lives and would eat
each other. Okay. All right. That's
the way it works and with eat you,
they would eat you. They
will do anything like, okay,
the real animals out there are doing
anything they can to survive. Yeah.
You saw that a woman who's the editor
from game of Thrones got pulled out of her
car, so I was like, yeah, fuck,
that's a real lion. That's real line.
That's not lion king. That's not, no.
And even if that wasn't a part
situation fenced in. Okay.
Like and not one thing. People don't
like lying is a big deal with me.
I've haunted line been on
many line. Huh? You eat lines,
you don't eat lines in general. Cameron
Hanes was gonna eat align for shot it he,
yeah. Well that do we need a shoe?
If it's fun but it's not the reason.
That's not the reason to go hunting alive.
Well what is the reason to go
hunting line to, in reality,
if you want to keep lines around
and wild areas that aren't parks,
you had to have a local benefit for it.
That's the best reason you have to have
some sort of financial incentive for the
people in the area.
Financial incentive for people in the
areas and also prevents poachers by hiring
rangers. Well or just like for
instance in this black rhino situation,
there wasn't anybody in there gonna rat
out where these black rhinos were at you
deal.
You go to South Africa and I was actually
hunting in a place the other day that
was in the middle of the Rhino
war. Okay. Well I was there.
They killed a poacher the night that
I, one of the nights I was there. Okay.
And it's a real deal.
Those people are having to lie
detector test their staff monthly.
Okay. It's real simple. I saw those
because the staff are, poachers,
their staff are tipping
off poachers. Whoa, okay.
People in the government or tipping
off Hoge is easy deal. Okay.
Well I just saw a white rhino in black
rhino. You've got to keep that in mind.
Okay. Black Rhinos, what you
shot. Yes. And a white rhino,
which was brought back from 30 animals
to over 20,000 because of incentivizing
people to own them and then being able
to sell them on hunting market. Okay.
And for whatever other reasons,
they were put into private ownership.
They went from 30 animals to
20,000. Wow. Okay. The white rhinos,
very docile and general. Not all
of them. Okay. And they're much,
I mean, you would, they're
just easier to be around.
A black rhino has not a lot of
tolerance and while there is,
I mean you saw that on our hunt. It
charged did tried to kill him. Okay.
So anyway,
um,
white rhino are just more dos all
they're going to be hanging around,
whatever that's easier for the poachers
to kill and obviously there's more of
them, a lot more. And so anyway,
it's just an easy animal for poachers to
get and somebody sees it on the side of
the road, they tip off
the local guy. Okay.
They were paying between 800 and a
thousand dollars per bullet on the black
market to kill these
white rhino or any rhino,
800 to $1,000 per bullet.
That's what a poacher would pay.
W what do you mean by per bullet buying
a bullet on the black market to put in
this gun and go poach a rhino pow.
They have to pay that much for a bullet.
That's what these people were
paying because they got three 75,
you can't go kill a rhino in general.
This freaking 22. Right. Okay.
So to get a three 75 or four 58 bullets,
that's what they were paying
two to get that bullet.
So they had to get the bullets through
illegal means as well. Absolutely.
They're criminals.
Right?
It's not like you and I are getting
together and going out there and saying,
let's go kill a rhino today. Okay.
And we're going to go get our bullets.
We bought fair and legal here in the
United States or wherever we, Bob.
I think another issue, um,
that Louis throw cop, uh,
covered in his documentary and that a
lot of people were not aware of is that a
lot of the lines,
or excuse me,
a lot of the animals in Africa to
being hunted on a regular basis.
We're on the verge of extinction just
today, two decades ago, maybe three. Okay.
And when they started
doing those hunting camps,
now these animals are thriving and the
reason why they're thriving is because
they're worth money and that, that
bothers people. It bothers people.
The idea that the only way these
animals are surviving and thriving is if
somebody is willing to pay money to go
over there and hunt them because these
people who were sitting there looking at
it ain't doing a damn thing to save him,
Joe. Okay, they're there.
Saving them to death by making
uneducated comments and throwing up.
Just type in 75 characters into Twitter
or your Facebook page isn't saving a
rhino.
It's making you feel better and these
people's feelings are in the way of the
actual conservation of wildlife to the
people who know how to conserve wildlife.
Well, this is something that, for
me as an outsider, who's slowly
ventured into the world of hunting,
I had to learn,
and that's why I kind of sympathize with
the people that are on the outside that
aren't aware of all of this.
When someone says, yeah,
I couldn't imagine someone going to
Africa and shooting these animals,
it's so fucked up.
I take a deep breath.
I want it to line conversation
defined what you just said,
what screwed up about it?
Well what's they,
their idea is that you're going
over there with blood lust.
You're on this orgy of murder over
there gunning down all these different
animals and posing with their, their
heads. That's their idea and it's wrong,
but it also,
it doesn't cover the reality of the
money that's involved in paying for those
tags and going over there and flying
over there and paying for these hunting
camps to stay open as kept these animals
in enormous populations where they were
dying off just 20 years ago.
That's a reality.
And it's the only reality that we have
documented in Africa right now as far as
conservation of a lot of these games,
especially outside the parks. Look, look,
a lot of the, a lot of the parks are, are,
are spared because they're
surrounded by gay management areas.
Okay.
And hunting areas.
And sometimes they have to take those
parks and they have to have either someone
come in and minimalize or,
uh,
control the population and kill some of
the animals because they get too high or
they have to open them up for hunters.
Yeah.
I guess the best way I
can put this is this.
Most everybody would agree that humans
are complicit in the plight of a lot of
these animals. Do you agree
with that? Yeah. Okay.
Then why shouldn't humans be complicit
in saving them and keeping them around?
Okay.
Through a traditional method that has
worked in conservation for hundreds and
hundreds of years. Look, the idea not
to hunt wasn't a part of humanity.
Humanity for just recently, maybe last
couple hundred years into the forefront,
maybe the last 30 to 50
years. Okay. It wasn't,
it wasn't nobody thought about it. We're
going hunting. Well before refrigeration,
it was like one of the only one you have
to do on a regular basis. 75 years ago,
we were basically an agrarian
society and a lot more ways. Right?
And people looked, they had, if
they're going to have lamb chops,
they're going out there and killing
that lamb right there. Okay.
How many people who eat lamb chops today
are going to go out and kill that land?
Almost none. And that's where
it gets weird. It's very
weird. And, and to you and I,
I've heard you speak about it
becomes very hypocritical. It is.
It's 100% hypocritical.
It's also wild debt.
The hypocritical is the most common.
It's more common to be hypocritical about
me than it is to not because of this
system that we've set up,
it's very effective.
That allows you to go to any store
any way you want just by me instantly.
How long did it become,
how long did it take you
to truly understand martial
arts and everything about
it? The long time. And you
still don't know everything.
I know. Okay. But how much,
how many years? I think I was probably
just getting started. About 10 years in.
You look like,
do you, do you think most people would
consider you an expert in martial arts?
If not, I don't know who is. Okay. All
right. And I get paid to do it, so. Okay.
You get paid to do it.
It's your life. All right.
So if I was going to ask you a question
about martial arts or a move in martial
arts or what it took you
give me a good answer. Okay.
When it comes to most styles,
styles, I don't know that much about,
then it's no different in
this, look, I've watched,
I can't tell how many fights that
you've done. Okay. That you've,
that you've been color for.
Okay.
And I can sit there and say
this or that or the other,
but to be inside that ring,
I can't imagine what that's like.
So I'm not going to say I know what
it's like to be one of these ultimate
athletes. I, I can't
imagine what, that's why.
I can't imagine what you would put
your mind through your family through
everything. It's the exact same
thing with this. All right.
I've done this since I was 16 years old.
Now I'm not an expert on wildlife
management or wildlife biology.
I trust experts when it comes to
hunting pretty close to, as you know,
you could ask almost everybody in
the international hunting community.
I think they would say the court
knows a lot about it. So it's,
you have to be in it to really
understand it. Okay. You, you,
you can't just be from the outside in.
And what it comes is there's so much
hate and anger, the lowest hanging fruit,
it's the easiest thing to reach to.
And today we're in a era of
rush to outrage. This technical,
technological, social media world as
it's just like a giant boom shipped.
And I think we're still lost
in that. And, and 20 years ago,
if I went on a rhino hunt,
nobody would have known about it.
Nobody would have cared about it. They
know hunting exists. Maybe they do,
maybe they don't.
And things went along.
Now the squeakiest wheel gets the grease.
The people who are the most outraged,
okay? They talk about
it, they scream about it.
And if you're someone who gets a lot of
attention, like your actor, comedian,
whatever,
they are looking at these people,
you know at their comments
and they look at the headline,
they don't look into it any more than
that because we have very short attention
span. News now is headline, headline,
headline, headline, headline. Trust me,
I know I've been a part of it.
You know this,
I've talked about the black rhino a lot.
It goes away.
And if some event came up and come
right back, as soon as it comes up,
it's gone again, you know, next.
And for the animal rights people,
there'll be somebody who will kill a
dolphin or stab a frog or whatever and
they'll move on to that.
So have you had a debate with anybody
in the animal rights movement?
Lots of them. And what was, what
was their take on this when you,
when you try to explain
your point of view,
he tried to explain that this is an
aggressive older male that's not breathing
anymore,
that had killed at least one young bull
was a danger to the breeding population
of an extinct or endangered rather.
Let me think.
Do they get an animal rights movement?
Like a hardcore,
I've talked to a few of them. Okay.
And after they get done talking to me,
almost every one of them, you know,
find some middle ground. Okay. Um,
animal welfare,
which was why I would say there's a huge
difference between animal rights and
animal welfare, animal welfare,
or I promise you, or you and me,
nobody wants to see an animal mistreated.
Nobody wants to see an animal suffer.
We understand that animals
are used for part of human,
human humanity and we probably wouldn't
survive in the world without them the
way we do now. Okay. Animal rights as
a total different thing. All right.
To some of those people, it's a
religion. Okay. It's, it is their life.
I would agree with you. Okay.
Uh, you know, somebody like
I watched, um, you know,
I really hate that, but there was a
person that you did, uh, uh, uh, uh,
you talked with on Opie and Anthony a
while back who's one of the leaders of
[inaudible]. Yeah. And so he comes
out and says things and you know,
he said a bunch of inflammatory things
towards me and towards anybody else.
Right. And it's not, it's not,
it's about his emotion about it.
It's not about if that, if the facts
were helping the black rhinos survive,
these people would rather there not be
an interaction with humans and animals.
They think the second of freedom of you
releasing your pet. Okay. Some of them is,
and if it got hit by a
car right over there,
that minute of freedom is better than the
lifetime. It being Joe, Joe Rogan's pet,
they obviously haven't seen my dog.
Okay.
And then they lump lump pets
in they lumped pets. Uh,
I'm sorry.
They lump animal welfare in with them.
They tried to make like that they're
bigger cause they get these animal welfare
people and a lot of those
animal welfare people hate that.
They don't want to be lumped in with
them. You know? Cause they know that,
you know,
like Michael J.
Fox said that he didn't look at an ant
in the life of the anti more or less
valuable than the life of his son. You
know? But yeah, he really said that.
Check it out bro. Yeah, but he's got a
disease that Shit's fucking one's brain.
Okay. Well I think this was
a long time ago. But anyway,
they say a lot of things like that.
That's an insane thing to say. Okay.
But that's, that's, that's obviously
you're talking about a certain,
that religious side of it, the ideological
side. And the problem they have really,
especially with me is that I had a
gigantic mountain of facts and scientific
material,
wildlife biology on,
on my side of the argument,
I talked with a guy, um,
for a different show and they're
doing a documentary on this
show called radio lab. I don't know
if you know, they did love that show.
They did a two hour documentary or I
don't know how long it's going to be.
They're doing a huge documentary.
One of the guys came over
with me on this hunt and uh,
I talked with this Guy Robert, I don't
know what his last name is. Crow,
which or something, you know what I'm
talking about. I know exactly. Okay.
I'm a big fan of that show.
Okay.
So I talked with him at length
last week and a half ago,
90 minute conversation.
And what I found is the more intelligent
the person you have this debate with
the much easier than Betas to have.
And so I,
I talked to him about it. He
didn't get it. He didn't get like,
you know what drives
you or me to go hunting.
But he told me I had one
of the best hard arguments,
if not the best that he'd ever gone up
against that this placing value on them
is going to keep them around.
At the end of it,
at the very end of the
conversation he was like, Corey,
you know you have a really great sense
of honor for this and I really respect it
is refreshing and I think you're right.
And so,
but it took 90 minutes of going through.
Like I said,
that a theorial mist of all the bs
that's out here about the, they factored,
fractured outrage,
manufactured outrage. Okay.
By a lot of times when
people are profiting off of
it, I mean Peta, you know,
killing all these pets, you
know, however many they have,
that's a hard part for people to swallow.
Okay.
Cause they don't know how to tell
people if they don't know the facts.
Well they're killing thousands of pets
a year and they just euthanize them
because they can't take care of them. You
know how good their disabilities. Okay,
so it's, it's extremely hypocritical. And
how the fuck did they justify that? I'm,
there's no kill animal shelters.
I don't understand how they
don't run something like that.
I look spay and neuter your pets.
If all these pets are spayed or neutered,
they ain't gonna be any, any
pets left. Right. Okay. It's,
you're doing,
you're dealing with
almost psychotic level ideological people.
You know,
my favorite ones are the people who break
into restaurants and release lobster's
back into the ocean.
That's great. You know,
I can tell you this for these people
who called up and are called me,
sent me messages, threatened to kill my
children, setting to burn my house down.
Right? My wife, every single thing
that you could ever imagine. I mean,
for those people to say they're going
to do that just in and of itself is
ridiculous and hypocritical.
Right? Okay. You're, you're
against killing, but you're,
you're willing to kill me. You want to
kill and rape and kill babies. Absolutely.
That had nothing to do with the rhino
at all and nothing to do with it yet.
But what my wife haunts my kids on it.
I guess I want to kill him for that.
They want to kill them. They look, I'm
mad. It's not about what you're doing.
It's about my feelings and my feelings
are more important than what you're doing.
If it's right or wrong,
and what they want to do is show you
somehow or another what it's like to be
feared or to be in fear.
To be came to my face,
Joe and said one thing. How about zero?
Yeah, zero. Yeah. Most people wouldn't.
Okay. And I will sit here and
talk with any of them. Well,
I think that's a real problem.
Social media, there were,
the real problem is the anonymity and
the lack of the social consequences.
When if I look at you in the eye and I
say something really fucked up to you and
you raise your eyebrows at me like, what
the fuck did you just say? And then we,
I feel that and you feel it and I feel it.
But when you just say something mean on
Facebook, it hits that person. You say,
I hope your fucking whole family dies
in a fire. You know Ryan's rhinos
are majestic. You go on about your day,
you don't even get a response back.
You don't feel anything in that.
That makes them mad too.
But I responded to lots of them.
Tweet him. I let other people respond.
I had a bunch of people angry at me
because I went bear hunting and I just
retweeted a lot of their shit and like,
you're a bully. You're a bully. You,
you sick your fucking followers.
I sick anybody.
You put some shit on the Internet.
I let people know about it.
I didn't even say anything. Can I look
at it? Do you, did you, do you feel,
and how many people came out after
you about the bear? A lot. A lot.
But I feel like there was a tremendous
amount of ignorance on their part.
First of all, because I do eat
bear. People were saying, you know,
you're killing it. You're not in
eating it. I absolutely hate it.
I like eating them.
They're delicious and you have to
keep the population down and you also,
you're dealing with an animal that kills
the Fonz of all the moves, all the elk,
all the deer that live up there.
Your facts are getting in the way.
Their feelings. It's true. Well,
it's also what Steve Rinella
has this great phrase.
It's called charismatic megafauna and
the anthropomorphication of these animals
like Yogi bear and Winnie the Pooh,
they are locked into people's heads.
These fucking Disney depictions of
bears are locked in people's heads.
This is what saving the animals to
death. Well, you know what it is is just,
it's not doing a damn thing, but getting
to know people, getting riled up.
That's keeping people look, it kept
the contribution for more money going.
You see what I'm saying?
But in California, it's
fucking up a lot of things.
California,
these ideas of actually mean California
doesn't even have a fish and game
department. Efficient wildlife. Yeah,
well they can call it what they call it,
what they call it.
It's run by people who are more animal
activists and they are pro hunting.
I don't know. I don't have no mountain
lions season here and because of that,
there's not a fucking mountain
lions. No, no, no doubt about it.
There's a place called the
home ranch that I hunt out of.
They have one waterhole that
they have a a trail cam on.
They found 16 different mountain lines.
What's imbalanced about what's in
balance about that? There's no balance.
That's crazy. These are the guys who work
on the ranch. They don't like it at all.
Not a goddamn thing they can do
unless one of them was threatening,
unless one of them, it takes out
livestock or becomes a threat to people.
They can't do a damn thing about
it and when that does happen,
then they have to fill
out all this paperwork. It
becomes like a huge nightmare.
They get investigated.
That's why we have a ton of game animals
in Texas and we don't have a ton of
mountain lions and
that's how it should be.
It's not like the mountain lion
population is in danger, not any way,
shape or form a dare.
Goddamn predators.
And they don't give a
fuck about your kids.
They don't give a fuck about your mom.
They don't give a fuck about anybody
that might have to be on that tray,
are not going to have the
predators for ethical treatment of humans.
Yeah. Do you think mountain lions get
tweeted when they kill someone's dog?
It's just we're dealing with the
extreme hypocritical situation.
We're dealing with an extreme lack of
knowledge about the subject matter and
we're dealing with people's emotions.
And look,
I have a lot of compassion for their
emotions. I understand it. Okay.
I care about these animals too. They
may not get it. Okay. And to me,
I've definitely did everything I could
from a personal standpoint of once I was
involved with a situation,
uh,
I went to the more liberal media
outlets to bring it to this. Okay.
I could've gone on Fox News and I've been
preaching the choir when I brought CNN
with me on the hunt. Yeah, he did.
Okay. So I, I went over there.
I was very,
very honest and upfront with them
about everything that I went through.
Everything they saw, they came and saw
the entire thing. And so if you, you,
if you, that what I've seen is they
got attacked because they said, oh,
this was a ridiculous, you know, y'all
were so behind him and involve this man.
That is crap. Well, you know what that is,
is if you don't share the opinions
of the people that oppose it,
then you're some sort of a shift.
They did. They did. Yes, absolutely.
Once they get there,
and that's the reality is tuition mean.
I had some conversations with people about
this when this thing went down and uh,
I said, look, I'm not going over
there to shoot and rhinos. I'm,
I've no desire to shoot a rhino,
but you've got to pay attention to what
you're talking about because you can't
just talk shit and say this guy's an
asshole and this didn't like Rhino and
didn't need to be killed.
You have to look at it from a balance
perspective objectively with no ideology
attached to it. And when you do that,
you realize that there's a lot of people,
a lot of conservationists,
a lot of biologists who are pro calling
of certain animals in any population to
keep that population healthy. It's,
again, it seems counter intuitive,
but it's important. What seems
counterintuitive about it? Well,
it seems counterintuitive to the
people outside looking at it.
I'm going to kill an
animal to save the animal.
Let's talk about the term endangered
for a second. You cool with that? Yes.
Okay.
Very crude drawing here of Africa and
let's say that if an animal is up here,
okay, and then you have or animal down
here, those are two separate populations.
So you'd, you'd made Africa, you cut it
in half, and then I went to south. Okay,
so are what they consider
East Africa, right? All right.
If an animal up here is in trouble
and there's tons of them down here,
you're going to see,
let you know whatever animal it is,
but it was not going to use any
specific on endangered this animal.
The same species is fine. Right?
Okay. Well also because Africa,
it's fucking gigantic. It's
gigantic. If you look at Africa,
this is the United States. Yeah. We've
shown that on top on the set before we've,
we've taken,
um,
an image of the continent of Africa
and you can put everything in there.
You put China in there, he put the
United States and South America. Yeah.
Rush is pretty good. I didn't, but
I flew in at crossroads or one time,
nine hours and never left the country.
Whoa. So big ass country. So anyway,
if the animal up here is, it's going
to be on the endangered species list,
even though it's fine down here.
Right. Okay. So for instance, in,
if you pull
up, go ahead and pull up southwestern
black rhino on Wikipedia.
Okay. And then I'll kind of walk
you through this a little bit.
I want to see him pull it up and let's
see if he pulls up the right one.
Southwestern Black Rhino is a
different species. Subspecies. Oh,
okay. So it varies genetically
in some sort of way. Okay.
Now look right there at the conservation
status of the southwestern black rhino
conservation status. Okay. What does
that say? Vu threatened their owners.
All vulnerable. Honorable.
Does it not say endangered? No,
it doesn't say endangered says
vulnerable. What's downs? Wow.
Why is it, wow. Because
it's not endangered in
Namibia. It's not endangered.
It's considered vulnerable. Okay.
Okay. And that's the IUC and list, Bro.
That's the list that everyone looks to
so least concern is the highest level
less concern is black tail,
white tail deer.
And then what's NT NT as near threatened,
near threatened.
So it goes from least concern to news.
That seems like a kind of a
bias designation to begin with.
It's not healthy population isn't even
on the list, it's just not least concern.
Yeah.
And even when you get into vulnerable,
you get in there their least concerned
that it's not a concern of going
endangered. Okay, what's a hell, you
know, healthy population, whatever.
It's not a concern of going in danger,
but it's right next to in danger.
That's the next distinction.
No, he's got lead. No,
it's right next to the threatened
Vu is concerned and lease concern.
Threatened. Extinct. Okay. And then
you have EWS extinct in the wild.
Uh Huh. Okay. So you have
to get into this. Okay.
The reason that they're not endangered
on this is because in Namibia has a
surplus amount of them. Okay. In Namibia,
it's not an endangered situation.
They have a surplus amount. Right.
When you say surplus, people say,
look, this guy's talking about widgets,
you're talking about tires, you're
talking about about thing, carburetors.
You know what I'm saying?
I have a degree in economics,
but you know what I'm saying? Like the
word, the term surplus to a living thing,
it gets people weirded out just at that
7 billion humans or whatever we're at
are enough of us. There was a
surplus people. Okay, so, so,
so my point is you get into
that in Namibia, they have
a surplus amount. Okay. So,
but as a, what is the population? I
think, Oh man, I can't tell you exactly,
but it's what I believe more than 2000
you know, it'll say on that. Yeah.
And the black rhinos, the ones that you
hunted or different, or the same as this,
this particular, that's
the one you hunted. Yeah.
So there's a few thousand
of them. Yeah. Well. Yeah,
that subspecies in Namibia and is there
other black rhinos is different kinds of
other different subspecies of
black rhinos? Like for instance,
when you were saying the one
that was going extinct in
the one that went extinct,
there was a western black
rhino that went extinct.
And what is the difference
in these rhinos?
Like how can they tell the differences
and different techs on many different
things about them? You know, different
versus a black tail? No, no, no, no.
That would be two different species,
but it's like a whole,
it would be a desert desert
mule deer versus a rocky
mountain mule deer. Oh, okay.
Something like that.
But like mule deer are weird.
Where the dizzy did designation is
the I five like east of the I five.
It's a black tail west. It's a mule deer.
Yeah, that's another right there there.
And that they could see right there.
They could be essentially the same.
It's just like this is transferring over.
Right, right. But you, if you shot one,
you would, it would be considered
a mule deer in a specific location.
If you shot the exact same
animal across the I five it's,
it'd be a black tea that day.
He's a black telling. Yeah.
So this is not like that
with these rhinos, it's, no,
you're talking about more
distinct diversity like here,
here, here. Okay. Okay. They're
there total separate populations.
So they have these animals,
they know that there's a fairly healthy
amount of them and they're trying to
maintain and grow the population right
through the resource of the actual animal
themselves.
So by,
by auctioning off this big game
hunt and spending $350,000,
they didn't take all this money.
It's accounted for very meticulously.
It all goes into this conservation fund.
It all pays for what rangers and w
was all sorts of different things.
It went into the Namibian game products
trust fund and it has a list of these
things. He could pull that up
too. Sure. If you want it to me.
But it's a list of things,
but you're, you're going
through it. Okay. So, you know,
basically it had for the u s fish and
wildlife to allow the importation of it,
they had to find a non detriment finding
mean that the taking of this animal's
not detriment to the species. And it
had to have a positive finding as well.
Positive, positive benefit.
Okay. To the species.
So do you have this animal now? No. Are
you eventually going to get it? Yes.
So they stuffing it for, you
know, it's still in. It's,
it has to go through a process before
it's important. The United States,
I mean it's only been, I don't
know how long, it's not even,
it's not been a month since I hunted them.
So they take it and they,
they're going to ship it to they yeah.
Tax a derm. No, that'll happen over here.
Okay. And you will just put this in your
house or something like, well, I mean,
like I said,
I've said this a lot of times I'll have
to look through it through what the
permit actually allowed me to do is my
personal property. I can't ever sell it.
I can't do stuff like that. Okay. Right.
But what I want to do and you know it
and I'm going to talk to them about this
once it gets here,
is how can I loan it to different museum,
put it on display at different places.
You know,
to keep an awareness a lot about it.
I never was in this cause I was like,
oh I can't wait to have a black rhino.
That's not what I was in this for. What,
what are you in it for?
Like what was your ultimate goal when
you decided to spend that money and take
that trip and shoot that run on what I,
I have a belief system in
sustainable use as uh, and, and,
and within that hunting as a tool of
sustainable use to keep animals alive.
So did you recognize this
was a high profile situation?
You would be something that you
would could use as a platform? No,
I now recognize that,
that,
I mean I was told that day when we had
the auction that my name wouldn't come
out for a, it came out like within
a few hours of the auctions,
somebody tweeted it.
It wasn't even supposed to be spoke of
right then and then it came out and I
kind of felt to be honest, bullied,
you know, I was like, you know,
I believed in this mud enough to
be a part of it now. Now it's out.
It is what it is. I can't do anything
about it. It wasn't my desire. Okay.
I knew it would eventually
come out and I, I do. No,
I don't think anybody could have expected
what would happen with it. I mean,
I didn't expect to the degree of it,
I've seen other things,
but I'd never seen anything
to this degree. Well, we live
in a new world. You know,
we live in a world of instant,
instant outrage and instant
reaction to that outrage. You know,
if this had taken place 20 years ago,
you, you really had no recourse, no one,
no one. I mean even if they got upset,
they got upset and they're small groups.
They read the paper together
like someone did you see this?
This guy shot a rhino. Fuck that guy.
And that'd be the end event. They,
there was no way to reach out to it.
And now that conversation
is for everybody to see yes.
For everybody to see everybody join in,
everybody to take the
moral high ground and,
and very few people to take a nuanced
objective look at it and realize,
wow, like there's this a lot of
gray area, like many things in life.
I'll tell you, really interesting
deal. When it first happened,
some children whose parents
were activists, okay,
they wrote me a letter about
why I was doing this. Okay.
They told you why you
were doing all they ass.
They asked me not to do it and
they did this letter. Okay.
And I did this interview with these kids.
I had like this guy was doing
a documentary about them
or whatever came down and
asked me if I would talk to them
and their kids, which, you know,
I understood that and was very nice
and very calm and cool with them.
I've had been with everybody
really. And, uh, they,
they asked me a lot of questions that were
really, you know, to me, I considered,
you know, most like common knowledge type
questions. But then I asked them this,
I said, if there's three
black rhinos left, okay,
and let's say it's one male or two males
and a cow or whatever and one's killing
the other two,
can you shoot that black rhino?
Okay, they're going to be gone. You
don't have time to think about it.
This is the moment. Can you kill
that rhino to save the species?
Okay. And the, the boy, the
older boy kind of got at this,
this is deep in the conversation. This
is after, you know, 30 minutes in,
he was kind of coming around.
Okay. But the girl was,
she was younger and she was pretty much
stuck with it. But I pressed around,
I was like, well, you know, look,
you've asked me all these questions,
I've answered everything.
Can you do this? You know,
if you really believe in the survival
of these black rhino. And she's like,
I just don't know.
And I was like,
well that's why we have experts that
do know and that they exist and that
they're in charge of this.
And so you yourself, Joe,
could you kill that black rhino?
Would you kill that black rhino
to save the species? Yeah. Okay.
It just immediately,
immediately just seems like if one of
them is trying to kill the other one and
you're talking about an end,
like it's a pragmatic answer to
a complex question. That's right.
Yeah. I have to do it. You have to do
or you have to let them go extinct.
Those are your two options. Your options
right now. Yeah, that's it. Okay.
If the one kills the other one,
and who knows if he dies in the process,
cause it's not like the ones got
to let the other one kill him.
They're going to fight.
They're going fight.
You can impale each other
with his fucking horns. Yeah.
They might get infected and die and
they might be the end of it right there.
So that to me, that's it. Look,
albeit extremely over simplified
question to a very complicated thing.
Right.
Okay.
When you're dealing with these wildlife
experts that put this together.
That's kind of the question
they're going through.
I mean that's part of the question,
but it's,
it's very complicated when you start
putting value on things and trying to
figure out which rhinos, which
you know way, which method,
which place, which community with all
these things. That's the big question.
What are we going to do to keep these
animals live and unfortunately for these
animals,
they cannot afford the morality of the
average person and the average person
person's thought process on that.
They can't afford it. Okay. You,
they need experts.
They need money and they need a value.
Anytime you put a hunting license on
something and you put a value on it, okay,
I'll hunt one time. I don't know man.
The second season of professionals,
we went down to Paraguay and we
went and darted Jaguars. Okay.
They didn't have going by you say
darted them talking about target,
realizing that rankle lives. Then they
could tag them. So we put collars on them,
radio callers and we moved one.
Okay.
If we moved it to get it out of an area
where it was the threat of being poached
by the local Indian tribe.
Unfortunately,
two weeks later it went back to that
same area and they killed it. Okay.
They're like, we'll give you
the Jaguar hide, but you know,
we want $80 for this color.
Okay. It meant nothing to them.
It had no value on it.
Now had that Jaguar then were 20,000
bucks or anything to their community.
They had done anything in the world to
protect it. It's that simple. I mean,
if you have gold running
around in your back yard,
you're not going to protect it.
It's,
that's why I have such
a real issue with these,
with people like not understanding this.
Just imagine this,
this Rhino's horn on the
black market's worth whatever.
It's worth three times a way to gold,
something like that. That's insane. Okay.
All right. Now, now that's
on a black illegal market.
Now if you put a value of it three times
the weight of gold on an illegal market
and you have no value on it and
illegal market, what's going to happen?
I think I'm going to kill it. They're
going to sell illegally. Okay.
Let's talk about, you know, I mean, I
don't know how far I'm going with this,
if it's even in the right direction,
but if you just put a blanket,
no. Okay, how well would that work?
Like in something like the
keeping people from doing drugs,
how well did it work on
alcohol and the 20th okay.
Blanket now and then you take enforcement
out of it. How well would it work?
It doesn't work at all. Okay. In Paraguay,
they had no way to enforce their laws.
They had no people out in the field
doing it. So what's going to happen?
This is not worth anything and was
going to get poached because there were
something that they're worse. Well,
those weren't even worth anything.
Nobody's paying them anything for it.
They were up negative benefit
to the community. They were,
we're worried about our goat. They were
killing goats. They are killing whatever.
So they're killing them just to protect
the lifestyle and their life. Look,
I mean the idea of death by wild animal
isn't something we deal with here in the
United States. Rarely. Very rarely, but I
mean, you're not walking down the streets,
la thinking this mount line's going to
fricking rip my head off today, okay?
If you were in like Zambia and you're
rolling down in the evening time in rural
Zambia, okay? And you're on a bike,
you're thinking line might be around here,
okay?
And you know people who have been killed
by lion, it's a different thing, okay?
Now let's say you live out
there, Joe, this line's ward.
Nothing too too. You Alive,
okay? Now you go out there, it's
killed some of your livestock,
your property damage. What are you
gonna do? You gonna kill the, okay,
it's killed your, it's killed your
child. What are you going to do?
You're going to kill the lion, okay? Now
if you know there's no benefit coming,
why not poison around here?
It's put some poison in.
This will kill the whole pride.
And that's what they ended up doing.
That's exactly what they wound up doing.
A lot of places,
people I think have a
real issue with monetary,
like attaching money,
attaching a monetary value
to life. People have, dude,
people have a real issue
with lots of things. Joe,
either people who don't hear the,
the,
the thing I learned about my situation
was you don't realize how many people
hate you just because whatever
you believe. Okay. You
know, if you're a Christian,
there's people to hate you. If you're
Muslim, there's people that hate you.
If you're an atheist, people will
hate you if you're, if you're gay,
there's people that hate
you if you're this desserts.
They're just not exposed to that level of,
Hey,
I got exposed to the level of hate
that people have for me. Okay.
Back in the day you lived your
life. I live my life. It was more,
I mean it was almost more of a libertarian
existence because I would never have
anything to do with you.
Right.
And Today on social media,
I'm in a room with thousands of people
that hate me anytime I get on it. Okay.
They hated me to the extent my Facebook's
gone, dude, I can't delete it. No,
I can't get on it.
It won't allow me to get on it.
What do you mean it won't allow me to
get off? I do it right now doing Friday.
So this is disabled. I put
my, I put my, um, my uh,
email address in there.
It says it doesn't recognize it.
So that packet the had to have,
did you contact Facebook
through all these things?
Through their method and then I'm
just like, I'm done with it. You know,
I couldn't figure out,
I'm done.
I'm not the computer genius or wherever
and I like announce that tons of people
under 20,000 people, you know, and uh,
that were just mainly a
lot of those 100 Biz gone.
And so they took my boys
out of it right there.
Well that's in a lot of ways it was
good for my family. If you, if you,
if you look at it like these four walls,
like Joe's got to go home.
He's got to be with his kids,
his family, right. Mild mom.
My wife would go on there. They look at
all the hate and it makes them upset.
I mean, I got skin thicker than the rhino
now you could have whoever in the world
sitting over here telling me whatever.
And I mean because of this. Absolutely.
What was it like when it first started
coming at you? A different story? Yeah,
exactly. Like just a giant rate, you know,
different like raging wall of emotion.
Like I'm angry,
I'm upset, you know, things like that.
But you realize that what made me feel a
lot better was a lot of the people that
would just say, you know, Karma type
threats. You know, wish you die.
I hope you get cancer,
or whatever.
I would respond to them when they'd send
me those message and nine out of 10,
maybe even more than that, said it was
just a knee jerk reaction, apologize.
They realize there was a
human on the other side of it.
So you think when they see you on CNN or
they see you on a website and see your
face, a photograph, they don't
necessarily think of you as a person.
Think of you as an expression of something
that he disagrees with that here's a
name on something I don't want to.
Hmm.
And you went back and forth to these
people for a few days or how long do I do?
I mean, usually the first message. Really?
Yeah. I mean, I, if I still had it,
I could show you.
How much time did you spend doing that?
I cared to ever reach out
to Ricky Gervais'. I would,
I love to talk to him about it, you
know? I mean, look, he's a comedian.
He can probably get it. I
searched his name, you know,
and well, he loves animals.
Yeah. I search his name and it came
up right underneath Ricky Martin.
It's probably good place for
him. How dare you, I mean,
he's living La Vida loca leave them
alone. Miami. Look, man, look at whatever.
I'm open minded to it. I honestly, I
think if he was setting here with me,
you've set with him, what would he
say? Well, when I talked to him,
he didn't have any problem
with what I was doing.
I told him that I hunt for food. I mean,
I don't hunt things that I don't eat. Uh,
and I practice very hard,
make sure that if I shoot something,
it dies quick. That's very ethical and
there was really not much you could say.
I don't even know if he's a vegetarian. Is
he a vegetarian? I don't know man. Look,
man, I'm living my life. My kids, Bro.
I understand. Okay. And people online,
I found out that they had a dog and
I'm like, what do you feed your dog,
motherfucker? Yeah. What do you
feed your dog? Honestly, Joe,
if you could bring him here,
if you could get that dude
to come here and sit with me,
I would love nothing more than, than it,
you know, I'll talk to anybody about it.
Do you think that there's like a certain
certain social currency to standing up
for animals, certain social
currency to taking that photo,
putting online and going? How do you
think, man? I think there is absolutely,
there is.
I think people do certain things,
not just because they believe it,
but also they put it out there
because they want everyone to know.
They believe it. Cause it, it jazzes
them up. Honestly, if he was here,
I would show him nothing but love. I
would, I care about him as a human being.
And he know he called me a murdering
scumbag. So he did. Yeah, whatever.
What about the Rhino? You shot a murderer.
It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
You're like a rhino cop. So look, if he
was here, I'd hug him. I'd be nice to him.
I tell jokes with him. Okay, look, I
understand. Hey listen, here's the thing.
I understand that I was in front of him
as an agenda. He's a comedian. Okay.
And he is a PR is a professional
comedian. Right. Okay.
And he feels passionate about stuff.
Okay.
He can say what he wants and I'm sure he
can take a joke as good as it can get a
joke. I would hope so. Yes.
Okay, sure. So, so, so I don't
have a problem with that.
I understand that. I was just something
for him to talk about that day.
It doesn't bother me. I don't, I don't
take any of this stuff. You know,
maybe you just have to slap a tad.
Personally I'd be inhuman to say
I don't take all of it person.
I think some of the personally,
you know what I mean,
but that's a very healthy approach to it.
That'll definitely help you.
I mean,
what are you going to do?
I'm going to sit there and look at all
the anger and hate in the world and let
that change me. If you set with
the devil, you don't change.
I mean the devil doesn't change.
You do the consequences of actually
acquiring food or just so much more brutal
than people want to imagine. Um,
chick chicken mcnuggets aside,
even getting grain, you know,
I watched this thing on the,
the machines that they use to,
to get corn and wheat from fields. Those
fucking things are brutal. They, they,
they chopped down everything that's
in that field and they catch fons and
rabbits and squirrels and just anything
that gets in front of those wheels just
gets churned up and sliced apart.
So the only way you're going
to buy grain is you. I mean,
you're going to buy it in a store
unless you're growing your own grain and
picking it by hand, you're most likely
involve in some sort of animal murder.
You,
whether you want to believe it or not,
it's the reality of being a human being
and these [inaudible] from who we are
and what we are as regard
to the cycle of life.
Don't you think they're trying to do
that because they are disconnected by the
system that they subsistent?
Absolutely.
I think that was one of the main
reasons why I wanted to get into hunting
because I recognized a big
contradiction and as a comedian,
as a person thinks about shit a lot,
I look at things that don't make any
sense and I just go, how is this?
How come this doesn't make any sense?
And so many people just accept it. You,
you just,
you just hit it.
You said as a person who thinks
about things a lot. Okay.
You didn't say a person to reacts to
everything that I see immediately. Okay.
You have the benefit of time so you
have the benefit of self reflection.
All right.
You are read about you a little bit.
You said to do the self deprivation
chambers, all these things, right?
You're trying to find out who you are as
a person and you're trying to find out
where you're at as a person.
You're questioning things or question
things that thoughts and feelings and
emotions you have.
I don't think by and large a lot of
people that live everyday live have the
opportunity to do that or take
the opportunity to do that.
I don't think a lot of people do.
I think you're probably right.
And I think there's also the reality
that we're all under the influence of the
momentum of culture and when cultures,
when cultures is accepts certain types
of behavior and certain types of behavior
are not prevalent like hunting,
that those types of behaviors that aren't
prevalent get mocked or minimalized or
misunderstood. And that I think
when you, you deal with the,
the system that we all operate under,
there's a few people that are really
aware of what the system really,
truly is and those are the people
that work in the slaughter houses.
Those are the people
that breed the cattle.
Those are the people that work in these
insane confined chicken factories where
they just stuff all these fucking animals
where they've made laws where you're
not allowed to take photos.
You can go to jail if you work in one of
those plants or if he sneak into one of
those plants and take photos of the
ridiculously inhumane conditions at these
chickens and these pigs,
there's different states have made laws
because it's inconvenient for people to
know the truth.
It's like no different than the outrage
that people had when you couldn't show
coffins when you couldn't show
a American flag draped coffins.
They were putting a ban on them in
the media after the Gulf war started.
And people were freaking out that like,
look,
this is my fucking family dying over
there and you're telling me you can't take
a picture of the coffin
that my family is on.
Cause you don't want people to
know the reality of people dying.
Well that's insane. It's
information. It's all it is.
And when they're trying to
keep information from you
in any way, shape or form,
it's always bad.
Make your own fucking opinions,
devise your own opinion or come up
with your own opinions on things.
But you have to be able to have access
to information to have a really informed
a paint.
Well and there's not been a day and age
that I think we've had more access to
information. And it seems like people
would rather get outraged than informed.
Well it takes a long time to
get informed about this shit.
And I know people think that
the, you know, I, I agree.
I agree to be fully informed.
Yes.
You could have watched these CNN stuff
that we did when you had a pretty good
idea, a decent idea. Okay. And then
at least if you read into the article,
you'd know where to go.
Right?
You can know to go to the US fish
and wildlife page and look at it.
But what happens is,
is people have strong emotions about
it and then they have with, you know,
opinion bias. Right? And I don't know,
I don't agree with that because it
doesn't back up what I believe. Right.
And you can get confirmation bias online
going to a hundred different websites
that are anti hunting and the anti,
the world's foremost experts agreed on
it. Okay. And like, and, and, and again,
I'm not trying to get away from what
the point you're trying to make is that
people don't have a real idea of the
reality of the machine that feeds us.
Exactly. Okay. They
don't have,
they're not,
they don't understand that they don't
have a personal relationship when they
bite into a quarter pounder with the
cow in the way that my grandmother,
my great grandmother who ran a dairy,
would they look at a quarter pounded
the way most people would get a potato.
Okay. And, and the people look,
you know,
just being around you seem pretty open
minded about things that I don't see as
you look at it across to here at the
person that's going to judge me for
whatever.
Okay.
The people who are judging us about this
by and large are doing it while eating
a hamburger and having a Louis
Vuitton purse. Okay. They're there.
They need to look within
themselves and say,
is the enjoyment that I get from having
this Louis Vuitton purse or eating this
hamburger?
What is different about that enjoyment?
Then Joe blow gets from shooting a duck.
Okay. He's, he's enjoying hunting.
He's enjoying shooting and Doug. Okay,
you're enjoying, I'm loving this
burger. I'm loving this steak.
I'm loving these shoes. I got, I'm
loving my leather seats, my BMW. Okay.
Is your enjoyment more validated than his?
What's the difference here? It's
a good point. It is a, it's a,
it is a good point that you will get
people that are absolutely outraged about
hunting or absolutely outraged
about the death of any animal.
And yet they're driving down the street
and there's just murdered animal skins
everywhere. You look it on
people's shoes, on people's bodies,
in their cars, in their briefcases. That
briefcase is covered in animal skins.
Every convenience store you stop at as
meat sticks and those fucking ground up
things that they turn into burritos and
every restaurant, everywhere you look,
there is no balance.
The hip
I see of it. Okay? Now if
you're 100% real legit, true, d,
Vegan,
okay,
who makes sure that on the level
of it growing in his backyard,
he's not affecting any animal's
life other than his house.
Took them a place that an animal could
live. Okay? So if you're that guy,
I kind of, alright, you know, I can
get you, if you're not that guy,
then where are you at with
this? Right. Okay. And are,
why do you,
if you're not going to go over to Africa
or you're not going to go to Asia,
you're not going to go to the third world
and either help fund or personally put
your butt on the ground and live to save
these things and protect these things
and care about these things and be
intimately involved with their life.
Then what are you doing?
Where were you at with this personally?
People need to ask themselves
these questions. What,
what value does a black rhino have to you?
It's another interesting aspect that
people get upset if you do enjoy what
you're doing.
If you enjoy hunting,
if somehow or another you
get some of pleasure out
of this hunt,
then it's bad.
What they would like you to do is do
it with total somber thinking and very,
you know, I would say lots of, you know,
I'd say probably the majority
of hunters have absolutely,
at least in a very mean minimal,
a certain degree of reverence for the
animal and like someone like Jim who,
you know, I have never met anybody
that had more reverence for now. Okay.
And like so,
and I learned a ton from
being around him and he was,
he went to IX extremes and
like we would talk about this,
we're representing hunters on this
show. Okay. We're representing hunters.
What we're doing, hunters are going to
watch this. Okay. We would talk about how,
what we thought, how we wouldn't
step over the animal. Okay.
Now you know, look, I mean if it's
down, yeah, it wouldn't step over.
We'd walk around them, we do
everything. We, we care for them.
We'd try to kill them as quickly
and painlessly as possible.
We talk and learn everything
we could about them.
Why would you not step over them? We
just, we just didn't think it was right.
So you have you had a conversation about
this lots. Yeah. Okay. And like, you know,
understand like one week when
we cut the cameras are off.
Now we're dealing with that. We're
moving around the animal to cut it apart,
to queer it right. To take
care of the meat. All right.
But right now at this moment,
especially the immediate mind animals
taking the life of the animal is taken and
leading up to it. Like I
said, I sat on the show,
I was emotional after I shot the
rhino. If you, anybody looks at it,
you can go back and look at the Nepal
episodes we did. We went to Nepal,
we hunted with these Naples Lee's Sherpas.
Okay. Who, lots of them were Buddhist.
So you understand Buddhas and a lot of
them didn't want to harm animals. Right?
And they hunted and they understood it in
a real way. How does that work? If they,
they, they, they, they're Buddhists.
They, they took people to kill it.
They were part of it to these PDS,
those people, dude, those people ate it.
The Buddhist said it, you're on the
side of the mountain, you're surviving.
This is no other options.
Look like they're eat rice or whatever.
I don't know which one's eight.
What. Okay. But a lot of say in it,
I saw people eating it because he's
just not a lot of options for, yeah,
you're up there and you're living there.
But anyway,
so I'm living with these people.
And these people like you,
you like you have,
you've developed relationships on a hunt.
Would you say the relationship you
develop hunting or any different,
have you noticed anything different about
it? They're very intense. Very, very.
You get a bond,
you understand the serve,
he understand a certain
aspect of a person. Um,
when you see them tested, and
like, especially in mountain hunt,
when you go hiking on these
mountains and you see people pushed,
you see people that are willing to
pussy out. You see people that get,
get too tired, too quick to
get mentally weak. And you,
you see people who don't and you see,
you see
what,
you see,
what their character is about when they're
pushed on New Year in an endangered
and in a dangerous situation when you
are, um, you're forced to be quiet,
you're forced to be patient,
you're forced to be disciplined.
You find out what someone's made of
because a lot of people are fucked up.
A lot of people were all add it up and
they can't pay attention and they don't
know how to stay focused.
And be a contributing
factor in a successful hunt.
And that's one of the reasons
why I think men in general,
we have,
um,
an aversion to people who are
loud but aren't saying anything,
call too much attention to themselves,
have a distorted perception
of their own abilities.
I think a lot of that boils down to that
would make a very unsuccessful hunter.
And I think these things
are ingrained in our DNA.
I think there's a part of
what makes a man a man, um,
or make some man what makes a man, what,
what people value in human beings,
what people value and masculine traits.
His ability to hold your own mud,
ability to stay calm under pressure,
ability to come through when
the chips are on the line.
And I think,
uh,
you learn a lot about someone when you
hunt with them and learn a lot about
whether or not someone can
keep it together when they're,
they have the shot lined up
whether they can, you know,
draw back on a seven foot black bear
and, and make the right shot. Yeah.
And so you,
you have
relationships and different bonds.
Okay.
It's part of like you think about people
hunting, mastodon hunting, whatever. Okay.
Throughout history, thinking about the
Indians. Okay. Think about everything.
Even you know,
Europeans,
there's things that happen on a hunt that
aren't going to happen in daily life.
They're just not.
And especially on a rural wild situation
where you are aware of what's going on
around you and your actions
have immediate consequences.
Okay. Jim and I had a rule
and Jim, I don't know if Jim
came up with or whatever,
but we talked about it daily and it was
the five rules, a hunting, safety, safety,
safety, safety, safety. That's
it. W W Aina, successful hunt.
If somebody breaks her leg or dies,
okay.
And we know a lot of people who were dead.
Okay?
And we would talk about this
extensively and we'd talk about,
you know, situations that we've been,
when people, we'd see people go, you know,
they would go bad and compounded human
error. You learn a lot about who you are.
And I've taken tons of people,
Joe, that had never hunted before,
people who are against it, whatever.
I've taken them from all walks of life,
from the wealthiest people
that exist on the planet,
to the poorest people
that exist on a planet.
And once you get out and you go on
that hunt and you're next to it,
it doesn't matter if you're a mega famous,
does it matter what you are?
You're all on level, ground level.
You're all on the same level.
If you all have packs on,
you're all equal and it's about what
we're doing and the emotion of that,
that that happens and the bonding,
you know, like for instance, Joe,
if you and I were on the side of the
mountain in Pakistan or Mongolia,
or we'd be at these people
and we're sitting here, we
have these bonds with them,
we're caring about them.
You think about their lives,
you think about how you
can help them financially.
You think about all these
things, you know, I mean,
you're bringing a lot of money over there.
You're bringing a lot of just items
like pocket knives and packs and stuff.
That means a lot to them.
You become personally involved with
these people and you and I become more
personable and learn about our lives,
learn about things, about our family.
We talk about these things. So we had
the time to do it when we're out there.
Okay.
And then you,
you find if there's a situation
where you know, like, uh, you know,
you've been in when people can die.
Okay.
I've been in those situations numerous
times and I've seen people get hurt.
I've seen all sorts of things. And you,
it's like a real, it's, you're, you're,
you're tied into who we are
as human beings. That in,
in a sense to where a lot of times people
don't understand what that is until
maybe they're in a car accident,
right?
They had like a traumatic event
or something. Okay. That's his,
most people probably haven't seen
something die, you know? And so it's,
you know, in real life, you know,
outside maybe they hit a dog or a
squirrel or something, you know,
or especially your actions that
caused the death of the animal.
You become closer to who you are
and what life really is and life,
I promise you,
becomes more meaningful I
believe because of this.
I think you put more value on life when
you've been in these situations. I,
I personally saw the way that I
changed as a human throughout it.
It definitely broadens the spectrum of
what you think our experiences. Yeah.
It gives you a completely different
kind of experience and in a lot of ways.
One of the oddest things that I found
about hunting is a lot of ways it's
psychedelic in that way.
Like the,
there's something about locking eyes
with an animal that's in the wild that
you're hunting.
You don't,
you're not thinking about anything other
than that moment and there's this weird
bond that you have with this animal and
when you take that animal and eat it,
there's a strange high that comes from
it and it's not a high like you don't
know where the fuck you are.
You're drugged up.
There's like an elevated senses sort
of a thing. There's a, there's a,
there's a connection to life itself
that's very unusual and it changes your
perception of life outside of that.
Yeah.
I think for each person it's different,
but I can tell like when you're talking
right now and when you're looking at me
as you're talking about it,
like you're very in touch
with who you are as a person.
You're very in touch with how these
things have affected you as Joe Rogan or
whoever you,
you know the person you are.
I think that's one of the best things
about hunting is that when you're out
there, if it's your family,
if it's your friends, you
know, is largely social thing.
Okay.
Now like in instances like you know,
the extreme cases where people who
like you look throughout history,
Kermit Roosevelt, Teddy Roosevelt,
okay. Exploring type things.
A different type of person.
Even Jim is a different type of person.
The and I totally different type
of person. Okay. When you're,
you're drawn to these things,
it becomes a real fabric of who you are,
what you're talking about. Just eating
the animal. Everything is spirit.
It's a fabric thing of who you are as a
person and you're in touch with what you
understand that the actions
you took resulted in the
death of a very real thing.
And the death of that really thing real
thing is sustaining year life at that
point and that societal alive and you're
talking about the emotions you feel and
that, you know, there's a lot of hunters.
It wouldn't even get it the
way that you got it. Okay.
Because you've thought about
it, you know, if they just want,
it's just so like it's such a,
it's such a complex thing and
that's why when people ask me, well,
how do you feel when you kill it?
How are you going to feel when
you kill this black round?
So important about the
two things that were,
that were most important people is how
I was going to feel about it and the
money aspects of it. Okay. Like it's
almost like a crime to have money anymore.
I think. I look at, people look
at money as a negative thing,
but everybody wants it. I don't,
I'm lost with that. Okay. And,
and some things I just give
up on trying to understand.
I guess that's the vast majority of people
feel like that. Don't have it. Yeah.
What it is.
It's almost like,
like looks like someone who
is really beautiful like that.
Do something negative about it. Like a
beautiful woman has to be stupid. Yeah.
If you think making money's hard, try
keeping money in this world. Yeah.
It's brutal. Especially if you're
spending $350,000 a kilo right here.
It goes quick. Exactly.
It goes really quick.
You know your show that you did with Jim
Shockey that uh, uncharted show. Yeah.
I didn't see the professionals but I'm
a big fan of that uncharted show and um,
it was a, it's a really fascinating show
because it got to show a side of you.
Um,
uh,
you don't really see too much of on those
type of shows and the Pakistan episode
in particular where you didn't want to go
to Pakistan, you had been there before.
It's dangerous as fuck at that time.
It was real dangerous.
Your family didn't want
you going over there.
Nobody wanted me to go on over there
and I'd been over there twice, you know,
and I'd put them, they'd all
live that twice. You know,
I've been over there like pre drones and
post drones and the mentality of people
were totally different. Really. I
absolutely, drones changed everything.
John Drones trains everything.
Fuck. Well that's the difference.
I mean we were hunting in
very rural areas. Okay.
We're hunting with people who,
outside of
the advent of the tractor and a cell
phone live like biblical times. Okay.
There they could not grasp a lot
of the things about our world.
A lot of them think that we
blew up our own towers. Okay.
I mean it's there.
They get a little,
they get media in a different way.
They get information in a different way.
Their attitude was just very,
very different.
There was a lot of people that were very,
I think it struck a lot of fear
and people and and so it just,
it was just a totally different thing.
And so to regards to the show is
not going over there on that hunt.
I'd already been there twice. I felt like
an and Brantlyn, you know, Jim's son,
I don't think Jim wanted brand would
to go either. Okay. And you know,
we had a very real show,
meaning like we did our very,
very best not to contrive too much.
Okay.
There's obviously things like we're
going to just like you and I sit in here,
I get here, you're like, Hey, I want,
don't want to talk about that too.
Where on the show. Right.
Those types of things. Okay,
we're going to wait till we're
filming. Right. Right. Talk about this.
So anyway,
it was just a,
it was a hard decision because I loved
Jim and I personally didn't have an
aversion to going there.
Okay.
But at this point I put my family through
hell so much. I couldn't even tell you.
I mean I've been everywhere on this
planet are a lot of the deepest, darkest,
horrible hell holes you can ever imagine.
And um, I just felt like, you know,
it's not, yeah, I personally thought
I put them through enough. Okay.
And Brantlyn talking to him.
Somebody I love is probably my closest
friend and a lot of ways and uh,
I love that guy to death. He, you
know, him and I had talks about it too.
Okay. And He, it was really, you know,
we did all these shows together and
it was a really big difference because
Brandon didn't have a
girlfriend or anything.
Most of showed him that
he gets a girlfriend, he's
getting married to now. Dude,
his attitude change. Sure.
Okay. Like he didn't,
he couldn't get a lot of ways until
you have somebody you're in love with,
truly in love with or you know,
like have kids like I don't need,
it's like a human being.
You are before you have kids and after
you have kids in the two different thing.
If you're a true father, a
true parent, you know, your,
it fundamentally change it to you.
Okay.
So my decisions were getting changed by
this and that's why a big reason why I
didn't continue to do the show,
you know,
it's like I done everything
I wanted to do with it.
I felt like I ran through the finish
line, you know, and am I gonna eat,
run the marathon? You finish. Do
you just going to keep running?
When you guys were up
in, um, way up north,
when you were on that polar bear hunt
with the Inuits, the local people,
you were a, I mean that was that, that
was a really crazy scenario. I mean,
you guys were essentially watching
them hunt, right? You were with them.
We hunted to you,
hunted to kind didn't show that
that much on the show because,
because a couple of the real reason of
that was the idea of uncharted wasn't to
do a hunting show in traditional methods
that we just went out and hunted stuff.
The idea of uncharted was to show the
way these wild places work and the people
who live in them and live off these
animals and their value they put on the
animal. Okay. And our value
for the whole situation.
And so at that point,
you know,
that show was more about a culture in
a lot of ways that is going away and
hopefully it stays.
So what was the choice was behind the
choice to not show you guys hunting for
the polar bear?
Because that was a big question that
I had had and he didn't show any.
Jim explained it really good and a
Facebook post about it and you know,
I think it just, it was more
about that than anything we had.
We had call ladies.
Yes. Extremely intense.
They're amazing people and that's
where Jim's hunted there a lot.
And uh,
those people,
he's like the Michael Jordan to a lot of
those people hunting as a part of their
culture. Like we would be in the airports
up there and those people love Jim.
Okay. They love Jim. He know who
he is. Absolutely. Absolutely.
He's hunting rich areas. He won't come
so she, I'll be, yeah, yeah, absolutely.
It's up there. It's the most
intense. Okay. They love him.
Well, it's such a
primitive, I want to say,
I don't want to say a primitive culture.
I mean it's obviously primitive,
but it's, it's long. It's to the bone.
It's been around a long time and they've
been doing it this way for a long, long,
long time,
and there's not much room.
There's not much wiggle room up there and
not grown any crops. You know, you're,
you're living in an intensely
cold environments and
there's not a lot of things
to hunt. And that polar bear
hunt is very important to them.
Extremely and wailing,
wailing more. Most important,
nor wall bowhead seals, all that. They,
everybody wore seals. They
wore a sealed clothes. Wow.
So look,
these things need to be protected.
Those people really get it up there.
Okay. They really get it for their life.
If they want to get a live their audit,
that's it.
Unless they're going to ship in canned
goods, they do all that. But dude,
it's a value to them. Okay. It's a value.
Just like when we bought that
rhino meat to that village,
you don't think they valued that?
What does polar bear it tastes like.
I haven't eaten polar bear. He
didn't need any, I didn't dude.
It was immediately frozen into a complete
rock. Right. Then just come like,
it was so cold. It was so cold
and Jim's eight and polar bear,
I think you could ask him.
I didn't,
I didn't get to eat polar bear
because we weren't those guys.
Literally the second
I shot the polar bear,
the guy who was running me running
the hunt was like this hunts over.
We're going home.
Okay.
And we let the polar bear sit there while
we were doing the things we were doing
for the show and dude it frozen into
a complete rock. And we're like, well,
I mean less than an hour. It's brutal and
we will all, and it was, it was brutal.
The skin at, at the whole situation.
How did they cut it up? Like a chain?
SARS and no, I mean, yeah,
but you could still get
in there and hack and get,
it just wasn't like when you've
dealt with them bear. Wow.
You know, and not be hunted. Bears.
Bears are, you know how bears are. Okay.
It's just a different situation and other
emotional aspect that people have with
it. They don't get, it's the
Klondike bar bear. Yeah. Like,
like I killed this gigantic
brown bear and you know,
people in Alaska get it by and
large. Okay. They live with a man.
Understand those bears kill all the other
bears. Right. It's just, it's just a bit,
some people just don't get it.
Tell us
no man,
I don't watch much TV.
That was the television show that was,
um,
it was hosted by the guy from the
Metallica. Oh, okay. Jay had bill,
he killed a big bear. Well,
he didn't even kill the bear.
That's what's really crazy.
They had a photo of him and they
use this photo of him standing up.
Like it wasn't him. It was a giant
bear like pull, pull it up, Jamie.
It, they thought that it was
James Hatfield. It's not,
it's another hunter that looks
like, and that hunter, he says, Hey,
that's my fucking bear. I shot that
bear. Like Hatfield is a hunter.
He does hunt. I think he's
hunted bear before. Probably has,
but the photo that they use to try to
keep them out of the gloss. Barry, uh,
was that Glasbury music festival?
Glastonbury. Music Festival.
See there's the photo. Yeah. It's not
him. It doesn't look like him there. No.
You know, now that you
look at it that big. No.
I mean there's a guy who said that it,
you know, he's like, look, that's me.
That's my fucking bear. I'll tell
you when I hunted it. God Damn,
that's a big bear. She, what do
you do? You enjoy hunting bear.
I enjoy it. I like to eat them. They
taste good, but the bear hunt itself.
What do you think?
It's interesting it's,
but the being in the woods with them is
amazing. Have you a hundred brown bear?
No. What'd you Hump Brown bear? I don't
think so because I'm not going to eat him.
Yeah. That's so far to where
my head is. I understand.
Do you understand that innervation
aspect of it? 100% yeah.
I mean if I lived there,
if I lived on Kodiak island and I
ran cattle or something like that,
I would absolutely hunt them. If
I, for whatever reason, you know,
needed to be a part of it, I
would absolutely hunt them, but,
and they absolutely should be.
Would you hunt them to raise
awareness about bears? No. No.
I would talk about it. It's not my job.
If I was a professional hunter, maybe,
maybe if I was on television.
We'll see.
That's the interesting thing about it is
the reason we hunt [inaudible] can be a
lot of different things. No, I
get that. I get that. Um, I mean,
the reason why I'm asking
a lot of these questions,
a lot of it is just cause I want to cover
all the bases and take it from a bunch
of different angles. Uh,
play devil's as much as
much as possible.
But hunting bears is a very different
thing than hunting whitetail deer.
When you're hunting whitetail deer, you're
hunting essentially nature's victim.
I mean these,
these poor bastards,
they run around and eating berries and
looking left and right and jumping away
and trying to, they're there. They're at
the bottom. It become a science in a way.
Hunting them. Yeah. To a lot
of people. Yeah. Well, I mean,
hunting deer is that you're hunting prey.
There's a prey.
When you're hunting a bear, you hang
a predator. Different situation.
Totally different.
First of all,
what's creepy about the bears is they
don't make any noise and big fucking
animal.
That was the thing about the rhino.
It was like a cotton ball made no noise.
We'll freaky 3000 pound car.
Dude, I'm telling you bro.
It was just like a bear.
It reminded me of a black bear.
They just know how to sneak around. It
was in sandy soil. It made no noise. Wow.
One time we sit down, we're,
we'd walk like, I dunno.
I mean we walked over 20
miles after the Rhino and uh,
this day we had walked about 10 at this
point and like the CNN guy was a big
dude bro. Okay. It was 200
8,300 pound man, you know,
and he hung in there the first day he
threw up and after seven miles he started
barfing everywhere. He,
but he really wanted to be
involved with it and he got it.
And uh, we sat down, we were
sitting down to the next,
that rhino 40 yards away that rhino
got up, ran off and we never heard it.
Wow.
Ran Off.
You could see where it just ran it
and they just really good at like
distributing their way. It's their
place, man. I don't know how they do it.
Like I've hunted elephants.
You would have heard that thing like
you would have seen it for one but you
would have heard it. You hear them.
Ron, you didn't hear anything.
I he never hear bear unless they want
you to hear him. It's the weirdest thing.
But the reason I asked you about the
brown bear was um, because I believe in,
in the United States of brown bear is
like similar to the situation with the
lion or some of these different
animals that, you know,
whatever you're talking about, you
know, certain animals that, you know,
strike things. In North
America it's probably the
closest thing we got, you know,
to that would be the brown
bear. Yeah. You know, and,
and they're hunted a lot.
People get it by and large and I in tune,
I guess to a lesser extent,
by and large, people don't
have as big a problem with it,
I think as they would African animals.
I don't know. I don't know why it, yeah.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that have a really
hard time around the power of course.
But there's a lot of people that
don't. I mean, you look at, you know,
even people who hunt, oh, there's
a lot of people in North America,
North America's, I'd never go to
Africa. You see what I'm saying?
So even amongst hunters,
you know? Yeah. I think a,
it changes the distinction whether or
not you're hunting something you're going
to eat or not. And you can eat brown
bear, but not that many people do know.
It's a management choice. What does it
taste like? Have you ever eaten it? I've,
I've only shot one and I hadn't needed,
it was eating a rotten sea line, let's,
and stuff that's gonna
make it pretty rough.
It had the ad eight the head
off of a giant rotting sea lion.
It was a picture.
Sure.
It would smell and taste probably
a lot like it, dude. It was,
it was an extremely,
um,
extremely smelly odor,
like rough, nasty situation.
It was really gross smelling.
You know, for many people don't know.
One of the most delicious meats.
Apparently his black bear
that's been eating blueberries,
blackberries. Oh God. Just ate the
whole head off that thing. Huh?
That bear had claim, that
thing that's, it was there.
It was laying right on top of it.
Where was this? That was on unit,
Mac Island in Alaska.
Way Out in the Alaskan peninsula.
And that bear had just was just laying
on it and I flew in out there and there's
a guide who set up the camp,
you know,
and we flew in and he hadn't been
there that long and I was just like,
well do you, what do you think about that
bear? Have you seen it? He's like, no,
I think it's big. I was like, well
why do you think it's big? He say,
cause I've seen six other bears come
up to that cliff and look down and turn
around and leave it like it was his,
wow.
This show was interesting that showed
the hunt because it was one of the few
shows that I've ever seen on
television that, you know,
like you give a lot of these subsistence
living shows, you know, like Alaska,
the last frontier or life below zero.
But this wasn't about subsistence at all.
It was about hunting to control
the populations in trophy hunting.
I mean that's what
these people were doing.
I mean they did he cook up
some backstraps on one episode.
Some people sliced up some, I don't get
like the whole thing about, like you said,
they go there in these camps,
just a trophy hunt.
The animals aren't getting
wasted. Right. Okay.
You're getting into what's drawing a
person out there to benefit regardless of
why he's there and his
mind, whatever it is. Okay.
If the result is good and
the result is benefiting it,
who you're judging his desires to do
something on what going on in your head,
you're not, you're not
looking at the result. Well,
you say that the meat doesn't get wasted
if you leave it around [inaudible]
brown bear, Brown bear. Okay.
The other animals eat it.
Whatever bears the biggest Predator of
other bears and barely eat them. Yeah,
they're all cannibals. But I'm saying
like by and large, throughout hunting,
there was only a few animals that
don't get eaten. Okay. You know,
like I said [inaudible] I
have shot some high end,
I wouldn't need hyena baboons.
My brother ate the lungs of about boom.
Whoa. On a bet. No,
cause he was hungry really well and that's
what the locals written. He thought,
well, if I'm gonna eat a part of it,
I'm going to eat their favorite part.
And it was the lungs. The locals like
the lungs. Huh? They boiled them up.
What do you say it is? Like he didn't,
they didn't act like it was too good.
I mean,
I didn't get into it.
We were in Central African Republic
in the middle of, you know,
the people in before the beat.
They just got the camp back
from the chatty and rebels
and shot it up. You know,
it was that, we weren't really
talking about stuff like
that. God, Bob Boone Long.
What is the nastiest thing you have eaten
when you've been hungry on these camps?
Have you ever eaten an animal that
you regretted? No, but I mean,
I've eaten things that weren't like, like,
like you said about the elephant Dubai.
By the time we shot the
elephant, we were hungry. I mean,
we just threw it on coals and
we're just eat it right there.
And it wasn't nasty or anything.
It was food. But you know,
I haven't really gotten into
something like, you know,
Jim eats that ego knuck okay.
Which is,
it's like fermented Walrus meat.
Oh yeah.
Like the Icelandic people doing sharks.
Yeah.
They just leave it out there and a ball.
Yeah. I haven't tried that, you know,
but I would try it.
I mean,
I've watched Jimmy a lot of crazy
crap that he's living a very odd life.
Jim Shock. No doubt. I mean, uh, and I
say that with all due respect, it's not,
I'm not saying it in a negative way if,
if you don't know, show just, I mean,
even if you're not in a hunting
at all, like, like you said,
that shows not really necessarily
about hunting that much. I mean, it is,
but it isn't, it's a lot of, it is a,
it's an in depth discovery of the cultures
that he's visiting and the emotions
that we like we would go
through on the hunt. I mean,
I'll cry it on the show twice.
A man I cried when I shot a previously
on the professionals when I shot a blue
sheet. And just because
it was just, you know,
we had a lot real ordeal and it was
just like a relief and emotional thing.
And then I cried talking about my granddad
one time and that was the Pakistan.
Yeah. So, yeah. And so it just,
like, we were very real about it.
We were everything on our sleeve.
And what is he trying to do?
Go into all these different, just soaking
up a lot of different experiences.
Is that his, uh, his
perspective on this? I mean,
you'd have to talk to him about it
and I don't even know if he would,
you know, I love the Guy, I've
been with him a lot and you know,
a lot of our life was connected for
over a decade and still is in a way.
Um,
and he's just,
he has a different attitude about it.
Almost like I would say some of the
explorers might've had in his mind.
I'm not saying that he has any delusions
of grandeur that that's what he's doing,
but he has a different attitude
about it. And I think, you know,
we both wanted to see
what's left. Like, I mean,
when you're going to Papa New Guinea or
going to the edge when you're going in
the rural,
I mean,
we're dealing with people
who were cannibals and
believe in witchcraft and all
sorts of stuff, you know, and I like
hanging out with cannibals. I mean,
look,
I shouldn't put,
I didn't deal with a cannibal who I
deal with people who knew cannibals and
understood cannibalism and we're,
we're afraid of it.
So they knew people. I knew, knew
it to be, they knew it to be new,
it to be a real thing.
Okay. And like for instance,
one time I was hunting in Uganda and we
talk about people's different attitudes
and stuff. Jim and I went to Uganda and
one of the first hunts when it reopened,
we're hunting animal called CECI islands
that have tongue. What's it called?
CECI island sit at Tanga with is that
it's an antelope that lives in a swamp on
an island. Okay. And
like mean we value it.
We love it.
But anyway,
so we're over there and they were talking
about this big problem they had with
over in a certain area of Uganda on
Lake Albert were that they were buying
bushmeat from the Congolese,
just basically almost
like from a grocery story.
We'd come across on a boat,
it would all be cut up and everything.
And the way they got the people
to quit it was, they said,
the con Congolese are still
on your human meat too.
And they believed it.
Well,
vice did this piece on Liberia and uh,
that was a real issue in Liberia.
They were selling human meat and these
food carts on the corner and this guy
recognized it as human meat because
he'd eating human meat. Yeah,
there you go. What, what the fuck?
That's, that's the difference between,
you know, the, it's a dis
Sherman oaks. It's a d,
it's the disconnect of what is really
happening. You when you think about it,
think about this, think about
like this war we have, you know,
going on versus Isis, right. And
we're sitting over here and you know,
I've been close back, you know,
to Al Qaeda and stuff like that,
when I would go to that part of the
world. Okay. I've been, you know,
on the border of Afghanistan and
probably in it and didn't know it. Okay.
For sure. And, and it's
just, it's a huge disconnect.
If you were over there and you see them
selling 12 year old girls naked in a
bizarre and having an auction in Syria
where they're just selling them as
property for sexual abuse, whatever,
sex late, and it's just there,
they've kidnapped him. That's what
they're doing. You're going to have,
if you saw that going down who isn't going
to be like immediately want this stop.
Okay. It's know that you're going
to, it's gone. You're going to do it.
I mean it's just the different mindset.
I mean that we have,
and I'm not saying that people want that
to continue in any way, shape or form,
but if you saw it you'd feel
differently about it. No doubt.
Well there's definitely different ways
of living in this age in 2015 and there's
some ways that people are living everyday
just to get by that would horrify most
people and what they consider normal,
what they consider normal. Yeah.
What is normal? Our normal
versus their normal. Yeah.
Normal up the fly river and Papa New
Guinea is far different than here.
Normal in a pygmy village in Cameroon
as far different. You're talking about,
you know like you talk about recreational
drug use. Okay. In Papa New Guinea.
They do this thing called
boo or boo way and it's like,
I don't know exactly what it is,
but they take lime and they take something
else they put in their mouth and it
has a reaction.
It's like a low grade myth.
People from this big all the way up to
grown people on it their entire life.
They're living in an altered state
forever and their mouths are red.
Okay. With this stuff, it
makes us nasty red blood.
So you're out there with a high
person that looks like a Zombie.
Okay. All right. And this eight people,
sometimes they're hot high person that
looks like as long as you see if you can
pull up bu way. Okay.
Just be u w a y, whatever.
Pull it up and see if you find
him. Papa New Guinea. Okay.
All right.
And Cameron and a village.
One time. I would say every single
person that I met that was like,
you know,
local people on the hunt.
I think they were high on weed from the
morning that they waked up to the firm
from when they woke up to
when they went to sleep.
It's just that just part of
their existence. Cameroon. Yeah.
It's just part of their existence was
there. Heart daily life was so hard.
They're looking for any kind of escape
out of it. Okay. It's just brutal.
I mean if you and I had to live in it,
if you had to, you don't understand.
I don't judge them. I don't have
to live there. Right. And you know,
you and I get to go home and
sleep and comfortable beds.
We get to take a shower
every night. I mean, just go,
just go challenge the average person
to go two weeks without a shower,
just go two weeks out of shower,
have one pair of underwear,
see what your existence is like
and then do it in the jungle.
Didn't do it in the jungle,
man of Cameroon.
Do it or wherever or on the mountains
in Afghanistan are mountains of Pakistan
downs, Mongolia. Gary is place that you
ever went to when you were doing all this?
None.
He had some scary,
scary ass incidences of falling.
You know,
I've thought I was going to
die from falling twice and
I had a guy saved my life
and Armenia went on to on
successful sheep hunts there.
And uh, I fell. It was horrible. I thought
I was done. How far did you fall? Well,
I was sliding on a sheet of
ice and I had my stick and it,
and I've kept my stick buried in and it
saved me and this dude risk his life and
came and saved my life.
And so I was looking down at
2000 feet and then going off,
sliding straight down 2000 feet and going
off a cliff and a few hundred feet and
then going down in the bottom. And then,
you know, I've always, I've had animals,
you know, the closest animal that
ever nearly got me was a black bear.
Where was this? That was
in Alaska. What happened?
Silly stuff, you know,
just real thick. And
I was hunting with a Athabaskan
person, you know, half and half,
or a person who was half Indian,
half white person and I'm awesome guy.
And we were walking, we were actually
moose hunting and I had a bear tag.
And uh,
I look straight down and I saw this bird
print on the ground and I looked at it
and I said, man, that's like the freshest
trackapp ever seen him alive. I was like,
it must have just been here.
I'm talking to the students like closer,
you know how you walk when you're
hunting. Right. And I hear,
I look up and it's climbing the
tree right here. Okay. We jumped it.
So I threw up my shot it.
Anyway, we tracked it and um,
it was really, really thick. Like those
of you hunted in Alaska or even like, um,
okay. Or South it, Bruce Columbia or
anywhere on the coast of British Columbia.
Yeah, I like those alders you know, it's
just nasty, thick brush. Right. And uh,
anyway, I couldn't see anything. You
know how quite a blackberry is, right?
So the guide sees it and he sees it. I
can't see, he's like right in front of me.
I'm like, shoot it, you know, if you
can see it, I can't see. Boom Dude,
it flipped out. It just, just,
just destroying everything around
big seven foot blackberry, you know,
just destroying everything around it
and it rolled and I shot in there, boom,
boom, boom. And I shot in there and um,
you know, I thought I'd got it, you know,
it felt pretty good about that and this,
all this whole thing happened
just like in a few minutes. Okay.
Just wasn't very long.
Right.
And then I walk over there to see where
the bears had him walking around. Like,
like, you know, walking and I'm
looking, looking, looking, looking,
and then I look in the bear
just like right here, looking
the opposite direction.
Okay.
So a very,
and just turned and just rule
Hodges went as I built him,
he fell back and she fell
back and shot it. Ooh. Yeah.
And that was just,
but you know,
different situations like as far as
the country goes, you know, I've had,
I had been a lot of different scary
places with regards to, you know,
people more than anything.
You know,
I've hunted Ethiopia couple of times
so that people were weird. Oh my God.
That's the guy. He's got that
stuff in his mouth. There you go.
That's what they looked like over there.
What's that stuff called again?
Bu is what they called it boot
way or something. I googled,
it's called a tell nut. Yeah.
It's some kind of nut. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's got some sort of, uh,
what's, what's the effect of it?
But tell him, well, it's obviously a
bad teeth affect on your teeth. Yeah.
It seems like it. Jesus Christ. Huh?
Beetle nut.
Yeah.
And it has some sort of a
narcotic effect or I'm like,
I've asked him and what effect is it
like that cat stuff that they chew,
that's a different, let me do that.
I'm not, you know, just a bunch of,
I don't know a lot about
drugs, so, but it's Christ,
it's a hard life.
It's a very hard life.
And you think that all these experiences
going to all these different places made
you appreciate your own
existence here in civilization.
More a hundred percent
that makes you really like,
just like the way people are abused and
other places and the way they don't have
rights of life. The value a lot
there. If you're abused, you know,
and you're just taken advantage of by
whatever the government, the local,
every city or just the situation, your
plight in the world. I don't think that,
you know, people say, well there's
no value of life. And I understand,
you know, they, I watched one
time a guy didn't want to spend
40 bucks to keep his kid
alive and let him die.
He said he already spent a
hundred and that was enough.
Oh,
okay. You're getting into real
situations, Joe, like that.
You see different ways people look
at it and Christ and so now look,
is this every person there? No, but
that's situations that happened.
Those are choices they had
to make. Wow. And so yeah,
like absolutely.
It makes me appreciate America makes me
appreciate our bill of rights and makes
me appreciate our political system.
Makes me appreciate, you know, we,
we pitch about things here that
hmm,
the other world would die to
have as a complaint. You know,
we're upset that traffic's bad.
We're upset that, you know,
my wife is mad at me then I'd
come home at five 30 and I said,
I've been with work. Right? No cannibals.
Yeah. Barely mean were, you know,
people are upset about, you know,
this transgender situation.
I mean, Dude, who cares?
You get to go home and hug
your kid and you got a whole,
the world's biggest army
dying for your rights,
dying for you.
You have a giant system
that's protecting your life.
You have people dying for you every day.
Does one way to look at it.
Another way to look at it,
people would say is that giant
system is set up by the military.
Industrial Complex to steal
resources was another country. Okay.
That's why everybody's coming over
here. Right? It's the best for sure.
This is the best possible
situation flooding in the camera.
But it doesn't mean you and I are on a
boat to get to that better life. Well,
we know that it can be better. I mean
that's, I think what the argument is.
The argument isn't, we should
stop complaining. So we
know that we know better,
but I'm just saying when you see it,
it's far better than New Guinea.
It's far better than Somalia.
It's far better than a lot of the places
you've traveled to. Yes, absolutely.
When you, when you do travel
to these places and you,
you do go over there and
you experience their life,
does it give you this feeling of uh,
like, like almost like helplessness?
Like you can't,
you can't do enough to help these people,
the system that they're involved
in the life that they lived there,
the community and there we sort of
entangled in. I can tell you, Hans,
I've gone on with my dad and,
and he
brought 20, full giant Cabella's bag,
just where the gifts for him, you know,
just given stuff at the very end with
my dad's named Larry would call it Larry
Mart. We just let them all come
in and just pick everything
they wanted, you know,
and giving them things to hunt
with. No, just soccer balls,
frisbees,
close toothbrushes,
anything,
you know,
and these are people that like need it
and this is not something that
anybody would expect from you.
They see this thing about you count on
the Rhino Dude, I'd be like so judged,
I don't eat whatever.
I don't care what people expect.
I know what my life's
like and I know what I do.
But you certainly must have some feeling
about otherwise you wouldn't respond to
them. Right. And they were
like the ones that look, yeah,
I mean I have a feeling about,
I try to,
I'm just trying to like bring
some awareness that hey,
maybe there's more to this than what
you see. You can hate me. That's fine.
Whatever. I don't mean, well CNN,
you know, like, like you said,
they came under fire because that's kind
of exactly what they said. They, they,
when they finally went over
there and reported they did,
they went over there and reported a day,
did actual real journalism,
which is getting rarer and rarer. We
talked to, we talked about that. You know,
the reason I felt
comfortable with those guys,
everybody in the world wanted to come.
Okay, look, it's there. You know,
they all wanted to come. The reason I
felt comfortable with Jason Morrison,
Ed Lavandera is I sat
down with them and I said,
you were going to have to come
to this with an open mind.
You're just going to have to come and
throw away whatever you got and when you
come on a hunting trip, you're
complicit in it. I told him, I said,
you're going to be there, your look,
ed, if the rhino gets somebody,
knocks both the dude's down with guns,
you may have to grab it to save
somebody's life and kill the thing.
You got to understand
that this isn't like,
I'm going to show him how to use a gun.
Absolutely.
I took him on a hunt beforehand.
I did all this stuff.
He understood I different hunt
before. Yeah. We went on, look,
I was taking people in there
have been hunting before.
I'm not going to put it
in there, dude. It's,
it'd be freaking a joke for me to take
them out on their first real hunting
experience. It's an animal. It's going
to kill him. I mean he's just like,
like I'm hunting just plains game
animals just for a day, you know.
And um,
you know,
I was trying to figure out who could
actually like make it and not get killed,
you know, make it not cost
somebody's death because you know,
when you're looking around
he get goofy. They, they,
a couple of them got goofy,
you know,
ed ended up being the only
person there and then the,
the rhino charged him at a like all
like the wild is crap turn of events.
Here's the CNN guy running at me and
come underneath the gun. What did,
what did he describe the
experience like personally?
What did he take away
from it? Boy, it was a,
it was a eye opening experience
to all those guys. Like,
I honestly felt like
one of them really was.
He wasn't on,
I mean he was kind of real ambivalent,
but he wasn't like some guy who thought
it was the best thing in the for sure.
And it was really pretty
open minded about it.
He just wanted to go there and report
what was going down and the true
journalists stuff. Okay. They were really
pretty hardcore journalistic about it.
But I think there, when we delivered the
meat, I think he kind of got teary eyed.
I mean he kinda got at that
point he kinda got it. And,
and the fact that man, this
is real, you know, he got,
he got a big experience out of it
because the rhino went for him. You know,
he was like, he got the fear of an animal
trying to kill him, you know? So he,
he had a pretty unique experience about
it. I think he talked about it on there.
I don't, I can't remember.
But he didn't talk about, he
didn't talk about, you know,
we didn't talk about the
rhino charging him, but he,
for somebody who wasn't
involved in hunting and they,
one of the smartest moves I've ever seen
anybody to where he ran, where he ran,
if he ran a different way, he probably
would be dead right now. What did he do?
Well, the Rhino, we had,
remember I told you that we jumped it
right and we sit down right and left.
Well then we, we kept
following it. And this is,
this is like the 10 mile point.
We followed it, we jumped it,
we it, we didn't know we
jumped it. We went over there,
we saw that we did and we
had so many people there.
We had to keep splitting the group up and
then they would come back up and like,
right. And so I told her, I said,
look man, if this thing goes wrong,
it's going to be when we lose the track.
Okay.
And so when we're walking along and we
lose the track and Handy Ph goes with a
couple of the trackers.
One way,
I go with a couple of the trackers
the other way and then I heard and I,
and it's behind me and the two guys in
front of me just immediately move from
about here to there. So I see them
moving and I heard it behind me.
So to make distance,
I just took these steps to get to right
there and then turn because I knew,
I thought, well if I just turn around
right here, it's going to hit me right.
Cause it was so close.
And how close man,
like 30 40 feet. Oh, okay.
It had bedded down. We jumped it. Okay.
And so, and it ran. I turned around,
I saw for that dude, that thing move
like lightning dude. It was like,
I don't know if you were watching the
bull riding dude's like a real athletic
bull with a saber on it, you
know? Okay. And so anyway,
it goes and we're really lucky and hint,
he came back and looked at, ed said,
look, and he said, if this thing,
this next time it's coming,
okay, we pushed it twice
as hot. It's going to come.
And so anyway,
we kept going and
I said, hey, hey Auntie,
I think he should go back there and
let's just split it up again, you know,
put them a hundred yards behind us.
Okay.
And we'll keep one camera man with me
and you and the trackers and then ed can
stay a little bit further behind.
And another guy who was there with us,
he goes back there,
talks to him,
comes back up to me and this is after we
walked into their 20 minutes or so and
I said, what's up? You
see how it's, we're good.
And we start walking and then
I hear just like some noise,
you know?
And it was the other dude trying to get
my attention from like 30 yards back.
Okay. And his voice was draw cause we
haven't drunk water and a couple of hours.
Okay, we're out. And
then I hear hint say Ed,
get down and get down. You know, just like
run, get down Ron, Ron, Ron. And I'm like,
well you know, I just plant my right
foot as hard as I could. I was like,
I'm not moving. You know, I
had time to think about that.
And like in this whole thing
lasted like three seconds.
So I had time to think about it and I
look and I see edge is flying at me,
like running like, dude, the cowboys would
have picked him up that day. That dude,
big dude, he was flying bro, like figures,
a huge motivator and he's flying at me.
He comes like coming from an angle like
right here where this moose goal is and
just ducks and just flies underneath
the rifle. I know what's coming. Right.
I know. He knew that you were going to
pull your rifle. He went, yeah, he was.
Well he didn't, he was yelling at him,
get down, get down, get down. You know,
cause we're really worried about
shooting each other. Right.
We're all stringed out.
Really what happened was,
I think ed missed the memo to sit
back and he started walking forward.
So when he started walking forward,
the Rhino had actually circled around on
its own track and in a way was sitting
there waiting for us. Okay. So
Hindi and I walked past it. Well,
ed starts walking out,
well the rhino gets up,
walks around this tree and starts
taking steps for him. Okay.
Like looking like this kind of inquisitive
and then just came dude like just was
like, like a Bat Outta hell. You shot
that thing when it was on a chart,
it was charging Ed.
He runs under he dude,
he like moves so quick and I like,
we talked about it cause I was like, I
was like talk to the producer. I was like,
dude, it's really pig pro. You know?
I was like, he's like, don't worry,
he's light on his feet.
You should have seen him at
Ferguson was like, right. Okay,
this guy's going to the craziest
fucking spots on there. Yeah. So anyway,
somebody had CNNS mad at Ed.
Yeah. So anyways, like he
comes flying underneath me,
the animals charging him and when it,
you know, they don't have good eyesight.
Okay. So when he came low, I think that
it was so thick that the rhino lost him,
like,
you know,
lost where he went and it kind of
just veered a little bit to the left.
And when he comes underneath me,
I just see it coming and turn in,
like just turning,
veering,
and it's like less than 18 yards.
It was right there,
45 feet and not boom, boom. Whoa. Yeah.
When you got up to the rhinos body,
what is,
what does that feel in like?
It was like a,
in this case it was different than
any hot I'd ever been on, you know,
because so much went into the magnitude.
I'd be like the magnitude
of the experience,
the magnitude of the whole situation,
magnitude being that like this
is like the most, you know,
hunt under a microscope that may be
ever existed without a doubt. Okay.
And so I was just like this stress,
it was going into it because we could have
shot the wrong one. Right, right. Okay.
What happens if the wrong one charges,
right?
You got to kill it and then
we killed the wrong one.
That's the worst thing that could happen.
We're outside of somebody dying.
What does happen when that happens? If
you killed, we don't bring it home. Yeah.
You don't bring it home, you leave
it. It's just that you're done.
So the $350,000 is gone and
this problem mail is still out.
That actually is the absolute worst
situation. Wow. And so anyway,
so what to walk up, have the
guy, you know, look at it. He,
we saw it from a game camera
that was on a waterhole.
We saw a picture of it and the guy said,
that's it.
This is the one that killed the
one last year. This is it. Okay.
And so he knew it by, there was ear
notch from where it had, you know,
when they originally dropped
that animal off there,
they so they could recognize it.
And so, and there's other animals,
you know the rhinos, there's rhinos
there. I mean it's wild area, you know,
and so the reason they're there
is that water is there. Okay.
So anyway, we, yeah, just
walking up to it was just like,
it wasn't like it's over cause
it really kind of wasn't.
I knew that all those
storm was going to happen.
You just didn't know to the extent.
Well, this time I knew, you know,
this time I knew it was coming mean.
It really was the most scrutinized
hunt the human race has ever known.
Absolutely. I can't think of a close
second there. What's a close second?
I really don't have one in mind.
I never,
I've never seen anything that got
this kind of scrutiny. I did. I look,
I've been involved in hunting my whole
life that I'd never seen anything like it.
And so like it was just like I felt an
extreme amount of pressure on me to make
sure everything was done correctly and
that's why I felt comfortable bringing
them. I felt like they were just going
to do an honest portrayal of what was up.
Have you stayed in contact with Ed since
that? Yeah, I'll talk to him. You know,
he was down at the flood in Houston
the other day. I just said, hey,
you know what's up and you know,
letting them know kind of what else had
happened since then with where the rhino
was at and stuff like that. Because he
generally had an interest in it. Like he,
he gave a damn, you know,
what is his take the backlash.
He got to experience some backlash
himself during a deal with the,
in Ferguson where the drudge report
reported that he showed where this guy's
place was at.
So he dealt with a bunch,
which I don't know if that was true
or not. I really didn't get into it.
I don't think it was, but,
um, I don't know. And anyway,
he had dealt with a lot of scrutiny
before, so he kind of understood it,
but he kind of felt a lot like you did.
Like anybody would,
they're threatening your kids. Come on.
You know what I mean? This is all crap,
you know? And I think almost every
person you would, even piers Morgan,
you know who appears, when did you
see my interview with him? No. Okay.
The first time I did an interview with
peers when we cut this big shark over
here in Huntington beach. Right. Okay. He
was all over that. That dude love that.
He thought that was awesome.
Long live your fish and this is
the coolest thing ever. Okay.
Like we were kind of surprised
right when we did that.
So then the rhino thing comes up and
one of the producers for that show who
calls me and I said, sure, I'll talk
to him. And so we are, no, no, no.
Ed called me and he said,
do you want to talk about it and
you're welcome. Thomas says, sure,
I'll talk to peers is how that
happened. Not Remember. And so I uh,
they got me on there,
dude.
And he came like guns a blazing
and at the end of it, he's like,
you may have a point with the
conservation aspects of this,
but what I don't get as
you're hunting photos. Okay.
So the rage about me standing there
next to an animal bothered him.
Like it bothers thousands of
people. Okay. And, and so, yeah,
he said it in a nutshell.
He said, you're right,
but don't take pictures. Yeah,
you're, you're, you know, you,
you may have a point,
but this is what pisses me off.
Well, that's stupid. That's
is just a photograph.
Why should you not capture that
moment if you're going to do it?
If there's no problem with doing it,
the actual act isn't a problem.
But the photograph of the act, that
enraged. So maybe pain. That's insane.
Well, he's no longer on the network.
Well, he's a douchebag. Well,
I wouldn't say that about a lot of people,
but that guy was involved in some really
shady shit in England with the tabloids
were the tabloids had tacked
into a victim's cell phones.
Do you know that whole story behind it?
That big,
a family of a woman who turned
up missing? They, uh, they,
they got hope because they found that
she had checked her voicemail on her cell
phone. Well, it turns out she didn't,
the company that he worked for had hacked
into her phone and they were checking
her voice. Oh, nice. It's
tabloid Shit, man. You know,
and that's a lot of what he
did was tabloid sensationalism
shit where even if he
had an opinion on something,
you know,
there's a lot of what they do that what
we were talking about before, they're,
they're trying to get social
brownie points. They're trying to
look, dude, okay, if somebody comes in
here and you don't have a gun and I do,
you want me to just let them kill you? Not
only that, the waste typically, I mean,
look, Ted Nugent is a funny character
to have on when you're discussing that,
but at the end of the day,
he's very fucking informed
when it comes to that stuff.
Very informed and pierce wasn't
prepared for that and he looked stupid.
He really did.
He did.
He understand like a lot of those shooting
deaths are cops shooting people in
the act of crimes like murder and
domestic violence and robbery.
And every time I talk,
talk
to it, like a big, or I talked to our
hand and talked to Erin Burnett on there,
talk to they,
they may have come at me a little bit.
They didn't have the facts right.
And the problem is if you don't
have the facts on your side,
and especially in this situation,
if you don't have the facts on
your side and you're left with,
I'm going to cut this guy out and
threaten his kid, you've already
lost. He was lost and in the, and so
they're just left without raging. Okay.
But that ain't helping anything, I hope,
agree with you or disagree with you.
If people are listening to this,
did they,
they get at the end of the day that
this is a very complex situation that is
not, it's not black and white. There's no
good guys and bad guys. And when you're,
when you're looking at
something like hunting, you're,
you're looking at something that has
existed literally since the beginning of
human beings. It's, it's
been a part of what,
what created civilization
in the first place.
What led to us surviving and that's been
somehow or another co opted by factory
farming and fast food and restaurant
chains and that has become our reality and
we are, our existence is entirely
unnatural and disconnected because of it.
Our relationship with the very
food we eat is delusional.
And what you're doing by by
being a part of conservation,
whether or not you know it makes sense
to people or whether or not they agree
with it or disagree with it. Once they
look at the actual facts behind it,
they'll see that this is not, you're
not doing an evil thing. You're not,
not only not doing an evil thing,
you're,
you're not doing a thing that even
can be logically criticized from the
standpoint of conservation.
You might feel uncomfortable
that someone's going to
go over there and shoot a
rhino. You might feel uncomfortable about
it, but that's your right. When you,
when you start looking at
the facts behind it, though,
it's very difficult to argue against the,
the idea of hunting as conservation,
whether you want to do it or not.
Like I said, I don't want to do
it. I don't, I don't want to go to,
I don't want a hundred rhino. I don't
want to on a brown bear. I don't want to,
but I understand it.
I understand it completely and totally
from the point of view of conservation.
Well,
I'm glad that you do.
I think it's cool that you do and I think
that it's cool that you're open minded
enough to get something that hey, maybe
you don't want to do. Because I think,
I think that's kind of the issue is like,
look,
I don't want to do a lot of things,
but I don't judge people who do.
And I definitely don't judge people who
actually have a stake in the game when
it comes to keeping something around or
keeping something good around, you know,
you uncomfortable reality of
attaching monetary value to life,
whether it's the plane's games,
animals that were on the
verge of extinction just a
few decades ago in Africa
that are thriving now because they're
valuable or whether it's because of white
tail deer,
which there's more whitetail
deer in American now than
there were when Columbus,
I mean,
we could talk for another three hours
about like conservation success stories.
How about elk elk than the veteran?
Just like Florida Panther. Even there.
Okay. Hunters brought that back.
Hunters brought the wolf back.
Trappers brought the wolf
back to North America. Okay.
And especially in like the southwest
or I got him Roy McBride, Google
it.
But so you can,
it's the people who live it have a
vested stake in keeping it around.
And if hunter, if you
have a problem with, um,
hunters keeping these animals around,
then don't go take pictures of a rock,
rock,
white rhino don't cause the,
the reason that why rhino there
cause a hunter's bro period.
The reason these whitetail deer in
big numbers because of hunters. Okay.
So if you're taking a picture of
it, you may not get it, you know,
and it's insulting to those who have done
all the work to keep it around so you
can have a opinion about
it that's justified or not.
Right. It's not, it's not, it's
just your opinion of it. Okay.
And it's there for you to talk about.
It's there for you and joy at
a price you didn't have to pay.
Is it convenient opinion? It's a
very convenient opinion. And so,
I mean it's,
I honestly think that,
I don't know
the average person,
especially when it comes to a lot of
these wild animals really needs to look
within their self and think,
is there a motion going to help
it and do I really need to do,
I hate this guy enough that he gets
cancer and dies just because he does
something I don't agree upon and then
go over to Namibia and take a break.
Go take a picture of black rhinos.
That dis situation helped stay alive,
period.
Okay. I get so sick of
the people saying, well,
just because you get money in Africa,
it's going to curb not every situation.
Give me a break. Give
me a break. You know,
my dream is for these children that live
there to have a heritage that we have
with deer that we have with bear.
They can go out to a wild place,
lay down at night,
hear a lion roar a hundred years from now.
I give a damn about that.
Sincerely.
I believe you. Thanks for coming
on, man. I really appreciate it. Uh,
it was a nice long conversation. I think
we, uh, we chewed it up. We'd shoot it up.
Good. All right. I appreciate you
bro. Right. Thank you brother Coy.
Knowlton Lazy Gentlemen.
We'll see guys on Wednesday.
Greg Fitzsimmons we'll be here until then.
Enjoy your life.